live okay folks so we're officially live
with
fresh and fit today our special guest
okay fresher myron
and uh if you're not following their
podcast they're absolutely
broke getting big you know just making a
lot of noise pissing a lot of people off
which is good and uh controversy
some people swear by their philosophy
some people go after them but regardless
we're gonna have a good time today to my
right we have a adam sosnick here and to
his right we have the legendary
white knight white claw warrior okay
aka future mayor of austin aka a friend
of mine when i was in the army 25 years
ago we were stationed at fort campbell
kentucky together from 97
if you follow the podcast you've heard
him call in
and tell some stories about his 20 years
in the military and fyi here's one that
everybody needs to know i'm married
happily
four kids 12 and a half years married
felix is married how many kids you got
felix i have three boys three boys and
uh uh adam happily single but somewhat
undecided and you guys are definitely
single yes or no yes that's that's
another challenge
okay however there's one thing you guys
got to know about felix um
to manage expectations here
if felix was 28 today he would probably
have a fresh and fit podcast absolutely
because he had a reputation i don't know
if we're going to get into those stories
or not but why don't we do this today's
about you guys uh appreciate you guys
for coming out thanks for having me if
you don't mind taking a moment and maybe
tell your background tell everybody
about your podcast and then we'll get
right into it yeah you want to go first
you go first me first let's go look at
that
yeah
pick your
rock paper scissors
never duplicated go ahead
yeah so uh they call me fresh from the
crutchfield podcast um i'm 29 years old
i used to be in tech i used to do
programming and coding as well and uh
basically um i used to do youtube prank
videos so i started doing videos on
youtube like gold digger pranks all
these pranks videos stuff like that and
uh i did an interview with a friend of
ours and uh he connected us together he
spoke on an hour-long phone call
regarding dating lifestyle money success
and he said hey you know what let's go
podcast
you guys had never met prior to this
never met before and this is how long
ago by the way this is like
you're not you know yeah going on almost
two years now so you guys have only
known each other in less than two years
yeah wow so much yeah we met through
another youtuber shout out to our guys
solotv84 he uh linked this up together
okay all right as you were well yeah and
then um we spoke for hour had similar
like mindset and we did the first
podcast it did pretty well you know uh
we did one a week and then two a week
then three a week and it became what you
know today freshman fit and then our
after hour show uh we went on a double
date late night and we were like lit
we're like oh you know what we're in the
studio two girls let's do a late night
podcast with some girls and surprisingly
it blew up from there and uh started the
after hour special that we have today so
the one time we were like lit because me
and french don't really drink but on
this night we we were drinking and fresh
was like bro you know what he's like
looking at me like all like blinking
like this that's how you know he's saucy
he's like
we should go live right now and i was
like what i was like bro we don't have
our producer here because he likes the
one i switched the cameras around
everything was just us he was like let's
just do it man i was like all right all
right i guess we'll do it all right
whatever so we did it and people really
enjoyed it and then we just kept going
and this was back i think january of
2021 because we started the podcast
october of 2020 and then we did that
first episode with girls january of 2021
and then yeah uh with girls and then
that's what people kind of like
like that's what made the channel grow
really fast and then from there people
came for the girls right they came for
the tits in the ass and they came then
they stayed for us after so you know
people have been like they'll come in
watch the girls they're like oh wait you
guys have content on like making money
and you know also like getting girls and
how to be a better man in general cool
let me stay around for this stuff and
you know hold on are you saying that
people tune in because they like hot
chicks that talk about drama hold on
what apparently so i didn't know yeah i
didn't know this has been hidden youtube
formula for years wow yeah wow
but my rent what'd you do before before
doing this uh so um mark gaines 32 years
old i was a former uh special agent
online investigations hsi um and i did
chrome investigations for
from 20
i came on as an intern in 2010 i became
an agent in 2013 i resigned uh in 2020
of december um because basically like
you know my my youtube they're like hey
bro you got to show what are you doing
here and i was like they were telling me
that yeah they brought me in and they're
like hey like you know you gotta chill
with this youtube whatever because at
that point we had like 10k and then like
we're starting to build some traction
and i kind of had to make a tough
decision am i gonna resign from the
government a job that i really did love
and enjoy or am i gonna you know pursue
this entrepreneurial veteran and i
decided to go with the latter because
you know i had people depending on me
fresh was getting ready to quit his job
we had a guy our youtube guy was moving
from chicago to miami so i was like i
can't just like tell him oh go back bro
go pack back up so i was like you know
what i'll resign if you know if it
doesn't work i can always go back to the
government um but you know it was it was
a great career i have nothing bad to say
i loved it like i actually started a
youtube channel where i break down cases
uh you know big celebrity cases
everything like that yeah it's called
the fed 1811 i talked about i did the
boston marathon bombing i did the rallo
drug trafficking case and i break it
down i actually read the court documents
and go through and give people a
different perspective from like a former
agent's perspective because i used to do
these cases myself so yeah i'm able to
give a little bit of insight but yeah
that's what i did before and then i
started the youtube channel fresh feels
originally unplugged fitness it was like
a fitness channel and then we started
talking about dating we we started uh
talking or whatever and then we noticed
hey we have similar
mindsets we're both womanizers let's do
a channel and then similar to a podcast
and we started doing a podcast we really
enjoyed it we talked about dating tips
and how to get girls and everything
because we're in miami both pretty good
with the ladies um but we figured it out
we weren't naturals you know a lot of
people say oh look at these two alpha
males actually you know we never talk
about being alphas we're nerds we were
guys that are words that just figured it
out so who were you in high school both
of you guys who were like 10th grade
11th grade who were you in high school
man well from barbados right so i'm an
island boy coconuts you know
in the wind
boy on the beach but i've been inside
for the most part playing video games
like you know online games smash
brothers mario kart with friends and
that was my life man and then what
happened was over time
started getting into like more partying
more like lifestyle and high school yeah
okay and then after that is when i went
to like um this area in barbados called
the gap right it's like a tourist area
and every day there's different girls
from like
canada you know uh uk from all over
germany whatever right so i'm like yo
these girls are pretty hot i started
dating those girls that were tourists
and then it opened up my mind said you
know what there's more to life than just
being on a small island i can go to the
states whatever
and say you know what i made a goal at
least in the next five years i want to
move to america and so said so done
against america
you know made my own way worked at
chick-fil-a basically and att taking
phone calls tech support
and now we're here today the biggest
podcast in miami freshman fit so yeah um
so for me i was i was a big nerd man
like i didn't lose my virginity till i
was 18. like i played yu-gi-oh cards
growing up pokemon video games all that
stuff like uh you know i just was a guy
that kind of like figured it out and
threw a lot of trial and error you know
and uh when i hit like uh senior high
school that's when i started to like
figure out girls i read the mystery
method you know um and obviously the
game these are books i think a lot of
guys start out with the shows like
figuring out how girls operate and think
um i also saw the pickup artist which
brought me which was what like back in
2007 on vh1 that's like kind of brought
me into this whole arena i was like oh
wow like this is crazy stuff and it was
like groundbreaking stuff that i had not
known like you got ned girls all this
other stuff um and you know people talk
about puas and make fun of them or
whatever but a lot of the stuff that
they say is legit and it plays on female
psyche to put you in a positive
advantage to be more attractive so uh i
read that stuff was fascinated then i
went off to college i was i went to
northeast university in boston i was a
d1 athlete i wrote um and you know i
started understanding the importance of
you know social hierarchies and you know
being on a team or having some kind of
social status on campus is very
important and then once i got out of
college i was like okay well now i don't
have the social status like that anymore
what am i going to do and that's when i
kind of had to relearn everything as far
as like operating it in the real world
and then i went off to texas that's
where i was doing my career i spent
several years just like working you know
season drugs and season legal
on firearms all that stuff and um and
then it wasn't until i came back to
miami i came to the miami field office
at 28 and that's when i like really like
started dialing in on like trying to
like learn how to do cold approach again
learning how to get really good women
again and then you know at that point i
think we had met when i was like 29 or
30. yeah and i was like you know pretty
much at that point doing really well
with
ladies and you're in the scene at that
time yeah i was at the scene because
when i was in texas people don't i was
in laredo texas which for those that
don't know it's on the mexican border
there's nothing there you know what i'm
saying no like absolutely nothing there
it's a small i would like it he would
love it over there
but uh but i loved it man i loved living
in texas i loved the radar of this like
a little part of me is still there but
um when i was there i was really focused
on working and another thing too is a
small town so like you'd arrest someone
and like everyone's connected in some
way so i just didn't go out into the
bars like that whatever and you stick
out like a sore thumb because as someone
who's not mexican you know me i'm three
and my parents are from sudan i have a
weird look like you don't forget me
right so you'll see me in court like oh
the hell i know what you do so i just
stayed inside most of the time playing
video games being a loser uh and then
when i came to miami i started like
getting back out there getting back in
the dating game and you know i applied
some of the principles i had learned
from college then from the from reading
and then trial and error figured it out
then by the time me and him linked up we
were full-fledged womanizers we were
figuring out but like people try to say
like oh y'all run around and say you're
alpha males whatever it's like no
actually we're the opposite of that we
just we're just two guys that figured it
out that makes a lot of sense i mean i
kind of hear a story he said you know
hey i was a nerd i was a nerd too i
think this might be a nerd convention
for sure revenge of the nerds yeah
exactly great movie by the way um you
know kind of the thing is you talk about
you know you kind of grew up and you had
this perception they were given i grew
up catholic and roman catholic went to a
private school played on the chess team
you know kind of those same things
playing video games you know we used to
play uh nintendo back in the day i don't
know if that was kind of date myself uh
you know ps1 those type of things yeah
anyway uh one of the things you kind of
mentioned too as well you know um you
know kind of coming your own you know i
kind of laughed one of my first kind of
experiences was when i was in germany in
1991 april 1st 1993 never forgot the
date the guy's like hey we just got our
paycheck patrick knows this type of
stuff it's payday you got you're balling
right on payday hey felix uh you're new
to germany because i just arrived there
in february of 1993. they said let's go
down to the red light district in
frankfurt i'm like the red light
district what's that all about man trust
me just come hop in the car we're gonna
we're gonna school you i don't know if
you've been to the red light district
you've heard those stories uh i don't
need to go into too much detail because
my wife will be divorcing me afterwards
and she'll probably want to have me
checked out but you have the right to
remain silent that you say cannon will
be
exactly
so kind of like what what fresh was
saying you know kind of i had this this
view of the world um and of course you
know that's that's really fine but when
you kind of get out there when i was in
germany i was in saxon housing i'm in
the red light district it's like just
completely different if you've ever been
i'm not saying to go but if you've ever
been it is absolutely insane it's like
going into a hotel and just picking a
flavor right you just go in there yeah
and you negotiate a price and they got
the black lights they got the music they
bring you in they they do the whole make
sure you're clean type stuff and and
these people they have to get tested and
stuff it's crazy yeah right i only went
one time though
that's my story i'm sticking to it
so but going back so yeah for you guys
your philosophy because so philosophy
with women with men with dating with
marriage with kids with money with
finance with health
everything it's inspired through certain
things you talk about the mystery you
talk about the pickup artist the book
the game all of that and then you know
what you did in college when you kind of
learned a little bit about the game
three years ago you come to miami
who had the biggest influence on your
philosophy and what is really the core
foundation of your philosophy um you
know shout out to our guy rolo tomasi
man good friend of ours the rational
mill obviously was was a great book it
uh you know connected a lot of dots for
me personally um and then you know if
you because the thing is with the you
know the mystery method fantastic book
gives you a great insight as to you know
how female psychology works when it
comes to attraction and what they're
aroused by but you know a lot of the
techniques in that book are a bit dated
you know we're talking about using can
openers doing cold approaches in the
club and bar um you know we live i mean
that phone came out i'm sorry well that
book came out in the early early 2000s
before cell phones everything else like
that so the game has obviously changed
but the fundamentals are still the same
when it comes to what is attractive to
women so um basically like from taking
that knowledge from taking the you know
the the red pill awareness from reading
obviously like the rationale whatever it
connected a lot of dots for me that i
already knew and um you know kind of put
things in perspective but you know we
kind of have our own strategy on how we
deal with things because you know times
have changed you know the data
marketplace has changed significantly uh
versus you know 20 years ago thanks to
the smartphone and technology and
everything else like that so we kind of
have a different spin on how we operate
how we deal with women in general with
the modern day marketplace but yeah yeah
me personally regarding um my influence
would be experience because uh i watch
and i learn so ask questions so i'll see
people like how do you get this girl how
do you have in this car how's that with
his lifestyle ask questions and from
there i applied to myself and i learned
from experience and also as well
yeah so
yeah so but what are the core
foundations so give me an idea what some
of your philosophies are so i the
biggest thing that i tell guys is um you
got to put yourself first right like you
got to put like your mission first like
because if you if you put women first a
lot of guys are you know more concerned
with like uh could we swear i don't know
if i should okay okay a lot of guys are
more concerned like chasing ass versus
like you know chasing success and yeah
that's great you know obviously you know
you got to play the volume game talk to
a lot of girls whatever but the problem
is that your retention level is not
going to be that high when you don't
have your stuff together you know what
i'm saying if you really want to be like
the best man that you can be you want to
be the best man that you can be and then
have women be a byproduct of it versus
chasing the women like yeah you'll get a
lot of girls from going out and cold
approaching all day and all that other
stuff but are you going to be able to
retain them and most importantly get
them to respect you and what i've
learned from dealing with you know at
this point we've interviewed like a
thousand girls on our show
respect is a foundation and that respect
doesn't come from unless you're i always
say uh competence leads to
accomplishments which leads to um
confidence and then that confidence is
what the girl respects because you've
already built a foundation upon from
that confidence that confidence has come
out of thin air you know girls say all
the time i want confidence i want
confidence translation and woman ease i
want someone that's established and able
to assert his will on the world and i
want to be able to follow that man's
leader and that comes from your success
say those three things again uh
so you got um confidence leads to
accomplishments which then leads to
confidence and that's what the girls are
attracted to is that confidence and but
that confidence has got to be genuine
that's why we tell guys all the time you
got to be congruent to who you are
because if you're congruent to who you
are girls are going to be able to notice
you know women have way more um
a better perception of social uh
calibration than men do so they're going
to be able to tell if you're about it or
not you know you can play the game for a
bit but if you're cap eventually they're
going to figure it out so if you're
really about it and you're that guy
she's going to be attracted to you
because you have that confidence from
your accomplishments so that's what we
tell guys is focus on yourself because
it's inherently going to make you
attractive in the first place and then
second on top of that you're going to be
winning and then women are a byproduct
of success versus chasing the women and
making them the metric assumptions so
far what's controversial so far
so where where do we haven't gotten that
yeah okay so where do people because
what you just said is
uh uh
you have you have two choices right you
have a choice to
uh uh uh date women through desperation
which is what a lot of guys do yeah or
you have a way to manage expectation by
setting the tone on what kind of value
you bring to the marketplace then your
pool and your options widens yeah that's
just how it works right okay same thing
works with uh
business as well if you have if your
business is predicated based on one
client you are screwed you're slave to
that one client
but if your business is you have
multiple options you have you know you
can have a little bit more leverage and
you actually offer better customer
service when you are because you're not
you're not leading that customer based
on desperation you're not begging them
they feel confidence from you but where
are some of the philosophies you guys
got where you lose people not maybe you
lose people but you get some people i
think it's triggered our stance not
cheating
um what that really means what loyalty
is what trust is yeah uh you want to go
this way about that yeah i mean uh so a
big reason why people get triggered is
that we have a lot of as you guys know
we do a podcast we have a daytime
podcast that we do monday wednesday
friday and then we do our nighttime show
with the girls and what since it's
longer form content where podcast goes
easily between
from two all the way to five hours
sometimes and you know we have
discussions with with women uh you know
a lot of girls from all different types
of walks in life we're talking you know
any everywhere from like educated women
to only fans girls to strippers to
models whatever it may be attractive
girls to not so attractive girls girls
in all different types of demographics
and people take clips from these
conversations and you know they take
obviously something that's like crazy of
that i say you know put it as a clip and
then put it out there and if you put it
out there it might look wild right so
then people oh my god you guys are
massages whatever but if you saw the
entire context of the conversation what
led to that you know portion of the or
that clip you'll see okay now that makes
sense so a lot of people clip our stuff
in general or like for instance for
virality sometimes you'll kick a girl
out yes that's like obviously people
want to focus on the fact that all right
get the hell out yep but what were the
five minutes before that you asked them
repeatedly hey stop disrespecting the
podcast yeah stop doing side chatter
i've been there i've been on the podcast
let me let me let me okay so let's go
let's go a little bit deeper let's go
shortly deeper because so far
uh uh i don't have a lot of things that
i have uh everything makes sense so far
to me define to me
how you view
uh what an alpha is and what a beta is
right i heard roller's definition maybe
you guys got a different one that you
have but how do you see what would you
define as somebody that's an alpha
versus a beta
and these terms man yeah we typically
don't even really use those terms man i
i know a lot of people use it
like you'll say you yeah what you call
them you said something about uh the
whitening the whiteness yeah who are you
talking about by the way
one of our supporters sent us a clip
right of him talking about us and it's
funny because like they're like yo this
white knight is simply trying to talk
about fresh and fit but he's a ship and
it's like yo real talk i don't know what
to do but how he was sounding it's kind
of i don't know i don't know so except
basically if i'm going to define it it's
basically a guy that gives his attention
resources energy whatever it may be to a
woman that isn't necessarily
reciprocating for what he wants which is
what nine out of 10 times intimacy so
that's if i'm going to boil it down
that's a simple i will say that david is
not a sip i will for the audience out
there he's actually you'd be actually
impressed with that dude he is maybe a
white knight but not a senator what's
your what's your uh uh what's your
long-term game meaning do you guys have
any plans of one day getting married
having a family having kids oh no
okay so there we go so not at all
well uh you know you can hit it first so
we have different different views yes so
honestly speaking um in the west uh in
our opinion marriage for men there's no
benefit at all they mean it for women
and as a result um most guys they come
into it blindly hey this girl loves me
likes me for me wink wink and uh you
know they get into marriage with this
woman and before you know it she's
leaving because her emotions take a half
of whatever you own and you're back to
scoring or even worse so in our opinion
regarding marriage like
you have to know what you get into first
and be aware of all the laws
from against men because
if you look at it from a legal
standpoint and like a logical standpoint
regarding the actual contract of
marriage it's like a contract that says
hey you know what at any point in time
the woman says i don't feel like anymore
she just leave take half your stuff and
as a result men are like either left uh
to the whim of you know women or for
example the mercy of them so we just say
hey you know what if you're gonna do it
probably do it without the state maybe
in church or outside the us because the
laws are not made for men to actually
win and i did it before in the past so
i'm actually married
when i first came to the states and
the whole experience man i'm not gonna
hold you it was it was good but also i
understood that hey you know what right
now my life is not for me and i have to
actually could change so it could change
one day meaning one day we can wake up
and we got a podcast from fresh about
how to keep your marriage together
i'm not too into that one 17 keys to a
healthy parents from a former playboy
zero views
i'll say this i'm open to change however
if i do get married again it's probably
gonna be colombia
colombia probably gonna be colombian
okay let me play colombia in colombia
yeah yeah stay in colombia would you
come here and i'll come back okay so you
would get ali from mayor i'll leave her
over there in the paperwork in colombia
the regulations of colombia yes and why
is that because the laws
what's the laws in colombia it's lacks i
don't do it with telesupport i don't
have to worry about being um divorced
great because at that point
i'm not going to be held under the u.s
standards and your standard are not made
out for men so it's great to not use our
word which is great are you more
concerned about the legal ramifications
of getting married or actually the
institution of marriage one woman or is
it a combination of both it's both i'll
say this let's be real here though in
the west there's not a lot of quality uh
leads you would you would say to uh want
to marry yeah really really in all of
the west what do you mean in america and
in the western hemisphere
quality women you can find good women
however the likelihood is very slim for
what you see nowadays social media
what's going on you know the feminist
movement is like bro they're
americanized yeah exactly but first of
all
you're in line though the the feminist
movement i agree but you know there's a
big push for that about being equals i
mean if somebody said something david
right now said something interesting
about this whole story with the girl who
tried to the guy who was ranked 456 for
men
becomes a woman you know apparently
transgender is ranked first and then he
says that's another perfect sign that
no matter women try to be men they can't
beat them but if men try to be a woman
they beat him at their own game so
that's what's that's what david said
that's david's comments right there
yeah but the point is you have a point
about what direction it's going and
it is a bit of the current society is
also probably discouraging younger men
of getting married because there's a lot
of fears and concerns you want me to go
build up my own well to eventually have
somebody take it away from me that's a
risk but also at the same time i can
address on that part is you know you can
you can have a job you can be a 1099
realtor
and a lot of guys just want to be
one-man shows you can go be a realtor
and you just sell homes right i don't
want to have i don't want to start a
real estate company with another guy
because i've heard a lot of horrible
stories if you start a realistic company
with another guy one guy leaves takes
after and done something
that risk is in business that risk isn't
marriage that risk is in every single
thing you ever do so you're right the
risk is there 100 but there's also very
good lawyers if you have money to have
the right kind of prenuptial agreements
which i'm fully forward if you got the
right lawyers how about yourself yeah so
uh my take on it is i definitely so we
believe in nuclear families and
institution of marriage like we think
it's a fantastic institution to be
honest with you to raise children in the
best light you need nuclear families
that's what that is the backbone of any
strong nation that's how the united
states was built that is how uh
superpowers were built was on the backs
of nuclear families right we know the
statistically speaking two-parent house
will disappear yup for child rearing
right however since we even though we
know that marriage is a great
institution for raising children
everything we just don't agree with the
way that is done in the west in general
the laws have not caught up to feminism
it has not caught up to women making
their own money is not caught up to all
the the social climate that we have now
right so we know you know about half of
marriages end in divorce we know 70 to
80 of those marriages are divorces are
initiated by women and we know that
about 90 alimony is paid for men to
women so knowing these numbers we tell
guys if you're gonna get married you
need to get married in a way where you
can kind of come in from a defensive
standpoint to protect what you have
because quite honestly when you get into
a marriage you're signing a contract
with someone that is incentivized to
break it and they will be rewarded for
it which is dangerous right to get in
under that premise so our thing is if
you can get married and not have the
state be involved that's the best way to
do it so like we understand the
importance of it but we also acknowledge
that hey there's a lot of dangerous
situations here that can really mess you
up from a financial standpoint if
marriage doesn't work and it's a very uh
it's a crazy risk and you know if
someone's willing to take it i just want
them to go in knowing what's gonna
happen if things don't work out and put
yourself in a position like you said
have the lawyers go talk to a family
attorney before you you know think even
think about walking down now with a
woman get a good strong pronunciation
agreement in place where you can have it
um updated every couple years etc so if
a guy takes these precautions and then
somehow finds a way whether it's going
to colombia going to dominican republic
whatever it may be getting married where
the state is not involved in your affair
so the woman isn't incentivized to break
up with you and destroy you financially
and or take the kids and use this as
some kind of like leverage point i'm all
for that because families are needed you
know that's for sure that's a good
argument
again i don't see a challenge with that
argument because
if you're getting married
and most people who get married they
believe in some kind of a higher power
denomination whether they're jews
catholics christian muslim it doesn't
matter so you want to get married by the
church so why do i need the federal
government to say that i'm married the
only benefit would be what tax benefits
is what you get which is some benefits
that you get not a lot of tax benefits
that you get yeah so maybe is that it is
that the only benefit of getting
selected but you have to tax deduction
the the argument of by the government is
a very good argument so if i'm getting
married by the church that's why i'm
getting married why do i need to get
married according to the government's
laws because you're going to lock me up
i also understand that part as well that
argument but but let's go a little bit
deeper okay so and i will say this real
quick too just to finish up um and the
reason why i say you need to be in this
defensive position when you get into
you're thinking about marriage or any
type of serious relationship with a
woman is because
women here's a problem and this is where
i guess we can get a little bit
controversial women want traditional men
but they themselves are not traditional
so what we're saying is that you're
basically a lot of the times what guys
do is like they get into a relationship
with a girl they might not necessarily
understand intersexual dynamics they
don't understand how women think and
operate especially in today's day and
age where women are more experienced
sexually than ever before and they get
into relationship thinking it's going to
be a disney fairy tale and next thing
they know you know the world flips
upside down because they don't
understand how women move today things
have changed significantly you know
women are no longer traditional however
a lot of guys come into relationship
thinking i'm going to be traditional i'm
going to be this guy i'm going to be the
nice guy i'm going to be chivalrous a
gentleman or whatever and that just
doesn't work anymore women have changed
significantly right they've been
liberated they're you know they make
more money than ever made before a lot
of women in general that we've from what
we've seen in our interviews a lot of
women don't respect most men you know
most girls look at the average guy be
like 50 k per year five foot eight not
good enough for me you know a lot of
girls overestimate their their sexual
market value as i was to say as far as
like what they think they deserve when
it comes to men and and we've asked
girls right we've even done polls what
do you consider yourself one out of ten
bro if i had a dollar for every time a
girl said 11 i'd be a billionaire at
this point you know what i'm saying it's
like
like um girls tend to grossly over value
themselves and you know there's a bunch
of we have a bunch of theories as to why
that is but um it's just not a good
market marriage market for most guys in
today's day and age in the west so they
need to get going with their eyes wide
open and come in from a position of
defense to protect their assets if they
are going to get involved in a marriage
because a lot of girls are not
traditional anymore and and you said
that my question is uh so you've now
been in this market now if we want to
talk it right for what a decade
yeah yeah okay so like if this kind of
defeat back patrick we're the original
fresh and fit from the 90s he's the
armenian and i'm the and i'm the uh you
guys got a podcast back in the day what
would have been called in the army what
what was the name of the podcast be you
tell me patrick i would say it'd be well
you would be the hustler that's for sure
you'd be the hustler felix was the guy
that would go to paul here's how it was
we'd go to uh pool hall felix was the
best pool player in the uh in uh what do
you call it uh fort campbell kentucky
the guy kicked everyone's paul newman he
was paul color of money but here's what
he would do we'd go to a place where
he's playing pool he's in a corner
talking [ __ ] to like four or five guys
and then he would say say something
say something because that's my friend
right there
and i have no idea what's going on four
guys are looking at me so you would be
the hustler i would say your nickname
would be the whole that's what walt does
with myron by the way he talks all this
[ __ ]
but i want to go i want to go a little
deeper with you sure tell me about uh oh
because
philosophies comes from different places
right one of them
comes from parents what what do you tell
me about your mom and dad what is your
mom's philosophy about what you're doing
that are they still together give me
that dynamic yeah so i came uh my
background is my parents are from sudan
they they came here in the 1980s uh you
know i grew up in a muslim household i
will admit i'm not the best muslim but
i'm i'm going to get there eventually uh
be a better one but um yeah i came from
two parent hustle my parents are
together to this day and it was actually
my mom that warned me about uh you know
uh western women in general like hey
don't make sure you don't marry an
american girl blah blah and i always
wondered like mom what's wrong with you
like what like what are you talking
about and then like as i became older i
started to see she would always tell me
things like she's going to cook for you
shingo i'm clean for you she's going to
chase her career more than you she's not
going to care about the kid she's going
to put him in daycare you don't want
that [ __ ] blah blah blah in my head i
was like what's wrong with you like get
out of here but as i became older and
older i was like damn okay she ain't
lying you know and it's a lot of the
times you don't grow to appreciate your
parents advice until you get in a
position where you can actually see it
with your own two eyes and it wasn't
until i was like in my late 20s and 30s
i was like damn my parents weren't lying
and my my mom hadn't warned me about
this my aunt my dad you know in general
about how western relationships are so
um and seeing how my parents operated uh
like as a kid growing up you know stable
two-parent household we didn't grow up
rich or anything like that but you know
my mom was always made sure there was
food and you know there was food on the
table and uh my dad worked and you know
he's the main breadwinner so you know it
was it was good to
you know i'm really happy especially
nowadays with so many people you saw a
good exercise in households yeah you saw
guru i saw a good example of what a
marriage can be would you consider
yourself still a muslim or no yeah yeah
you would so you still are yeah that's
your faith that's your denomination yes
i'm not the best one but i'm going to
totally get it haram
non-practice
i'm a non-practicing so here's here's
here's what uh here's what i would say
so but long term you may we may one day
find you being married with kids oh yeah
yeah like i would do it but i would
definitely take like
my steps that i'm gonna take are i'm not
gonna lie are probably pretty extreme of
what i'm gonna do my strategy but um but
you know that's just kind of where we
are now are you going to be married
before 40.
i don't know about that maybe a little
bit later but i plan to like leave the
united states to do that like i'm
probably going to go to like you know
dubai and middle east saudi arabia is
that what you mean by that you're going
to get somebody from your community from
sudan yeah yeah not sudan but like
somewhere from the middle east that has
like a muslim background and everything
i tell you so far to me
uh uh i'm i i get all the
stuff but here's one thing i will tell
you there's one thing i will tell you
uh that i think we don't pay enough
attention to so okay so i'm not the best
muslim but i'm a muslim right like for
me my parents were christians but i'm
like i'm an atheist there's no way in
the world i believe in a god with what
i've seen with bombs people dying
blowing up you're on all this [ __ ]
i'm like there's no god what you guys
are that's for naive people but fine
if i say i'm a religion i'm a christian
because the lineage is the parents right
here's what you got to realize
if
your mom says what she said to him
that's the bible
meaning your mom becomes your god
let me let me unpack that a little bit
and i may be wrong just hear me out yeah
sure if if a mom says
be careful with these western girls be
careful with this and be careful with
that be careful with that
and and the the
the form of affirmation was like not
once not she's probably told you that
many many times affirmations work and
then it sticks so for me
when i was a my dad and my mom got a
divorce so it's a slightly different
story i don't know they got divorced
twice and i think they were like legit
wanted to get a divorce but they kept
coming back because maybe this is going
to work out but they finally got a
divorce 20 years later
and my dad is a similar philosophy to
your mom so my dad and your mom are very
similar yeah okay with what he says
don't waste your time with all these
girls and let me tell you all the girls
lied and all the girls and you got to
realize my dad is my hero and i love my
dad my dad's probably listening to this
right now cracking up with you same same
yeah so we got a great relationship
together but one day he kept saying this
you know women are this and women are
dead and women are this you know
relationship goes bad relationship goes
bad relationship goes bad relationship
goes bad and i'm finally like screw this
i'm just going to go play and all this
other stuff and i'm like 26 27 28 and
then we had a moment and here's what the
moment was
i start reading god knows how many books
i'm devouring books left and right that
became my like if i'm not going to
church my books became my god at 20 25
years old i eventually uh went to church
and i 25 26 whatever it was 2004 is when
i kind of started putting my life a
little bit more together trying to live
by some values but here's what what
happened one day my dad and i had a
moment i sat and i said okay we give a
little bit too much credibility to our
parents to know everything and they
don't we give a little bit too much
credibility to our mom and dad that they
know it all and at one point we have to
question like even my kids they have to
question some of my philosophies and say
daddy i don't know what the hell you're
talking about when it comes down to xyz
fine question it right so i sat there
and i said do my parents love me check
okay uh do my parents without them
there's no way i'd be in america i'm
indebted to them for the rest of my life
check
my parents food do i love it one million
percent check do i enjoy their company
check and i went through all this thing
do they know how money works hell to the
no
so that's an x right okay do they know
there are 17 keys to marriage uh no okay
do they know how to eliminate their
in-laws from getting involved hell no
because their in-laws were a little bit
too involved and they kind of screwed
the whole thing up do they know the keys
to how to find the right husband or wife
no because back in the days it was more
to your range you know hey you made the
you know you come and you know kind of
do that
and then one day i come on my dad's like
let me tell you all girls are this i
said dad stop and we have this you know
he knows the scene exactly so that i
don't want to hear it anymore
i don't want to hear this anymore don't
pass down your limiting beliefs to me
you got to stop that's your limiting
belief okay if that was your limiting
belief and you had a bad marriage or a
bad life i don't want to hear about it
that's yours i love my mom i love you
but i don't want that to be me do you
want me to also go through the same life
he said no then stop saying that to me
so we had a very and i'm underestimating
what this was it was a very heated
moment we didn't talk for a week week
later this is why my dad's my hero
because he's able to do this he comes to
me
uh and my dad's an april 10 baby so he's
like very much to himself independent he
doesn't rely on anybody else he's his
own man
and one day we're sitting there he just
it's quiet he says uh you're right
i said what he says you're right and my
dad won't say that he says you're right
i said what am i right with he says
you're right i've thought about it for a
week you shouldn't let my fears pass
down to you you're right
and i'm like holy freaking moldy right
i got the chills all over my body
because i love this man i love my mom i
want to live a good life i want to one
day give you grandkids but my dad also
said the following thing which is
exactly i can't say the whole thing what
he said he said listen before you get
married
date every single nationality
do it in every place you possibly can he
would say if you can do it on the phone
booth that's it that's it's not the 60s
he said you know you've made it when
you've done it in the phone booth and
you know playing all this other stuff he
goes through then when you get that out
of your system then it's a little bit
more where you're not going to be
sitting there saying hey you know i kind
of feel like i missed that then later on
you're like i kind of missed the party
life i'm definitely not going to have a
reputation i haven't missed the party
live yeah so that's the part so for your
for mom to say that
i mean in your religion my religion
where we come from from the middle east
iran mom is like you know for mom to say
that so i i fully understand that but i
think there's a there's a lot of depth
in your philosophies i don't think you
got to where you are right now
accidentally yeah no well so so um going
back to what you were saying there so
like no 100 like you know obviously you
can't let your parents view points like
shape your world without necessarily
experiencing but what i was saying was
like when i was younger i was like i
challenged it then i was like what's
wrong with you like what the hell like
you know but as i became older i just
saw it through my own natural experience
what she said was true so it was a
little bit more profound for me because
i saw it through my own experiences
because at first i was like i don't know
if you're trying to be selective though
could that be selective could that be
just
uh accidental i wish it was man but it's
it's like you're young though you're 32
years old you're still young so here's
the thing so we um so at this point
we've interviewed well over a thousand
girls yeah and we and we've noticed that
there's certain trends in certain uh
mindsets certain beliefs software type
of uh yeah and we always say you know
just because the hardware is different
does not necessarily mean the software
is going to be different the software is
almost always the same but the hardware
is different right and what i mean by
that is that in general there's this a
belief system
in first world countries you know where
feminism is strong where women think
that they're equal to you or a lot of
the times they don't necessarily want to
do certain duties that women used to do
before in other words your roles as a
man are static you're expected to be
masculine the protector the provider
central the leader but her roles are
negotiable she can pick and choose when
she wants to cook she can pick and
choose when she wants to be feminine she
can pick and choose when she wants to be
a lady and my thing is uh you know i
wasn't until i became older that i
realized that and then from interviewing
all the girls that we do going on dates
my anecdotal experience and then in
general talking with we also talk with
thousands of men as well because we talk
with both men and women if you ever
watch our show we get super chats and
donations from all over the world and uh
you know it's always english speaking
first world country a lot of times you
know south africa australia new zealand
whatever and all these guys are dealing
with the same issues so i was like damn
okay so it's not just you know what my
mom said it's like now i actually see it
when my own two eyes were from any of
the girls from guys coming to us
and it's just like it's been reconfirmed
a million times over and over and now is
that to say that every girl is terrible
in the west don't marry them no i'm not
saying that but what i am saying is that
there's
tends to be this very similar mindset
when it comes to intersectional dynamics
with a lot of modern-day women that
don't necessarily uh that won't lead to
a fruitful relationship if you don't
know what you're doing i think if
anything guys really got to be on your
p's and q's in today's day and age more
so than 20 years ago no i mean listen in
regards to that i i fully agree with you
but i will also tell you this listen
being in the investment world for 20
years uh uh i don't know how many times
i gave a hundred thousand dollars to
this deal fifty thousand dollars to this
deal two hundred thousand dollars and
nothing happened and also one of them
boom 28 million boom you get them and
you're like oh [ __ ] so none of this
stuff work you know screw the
entrepreneur they help with the
investment none of these guys are
workers but you got to have a little bit
of that so of course i think the part
where
uh uh uh you know on in regards to the
parents when you're saying mom that all
that uh all that other stuff
they have um
i watched this video with this guy on
wendy williams he was in the movie black
panther who's the guy uh one of the
actors very good actor tyler can you
pull up black panther anyways this guy's
in chadwick boseman
jordan uh no no there was another the
guy from creed uh uh oh man that's
michael b jordan no not him there's
another guy let me see can you go to the
imdb anyways he's on when you go to the
top because the pictures are uh
daniel which one it is uh man i don't
know who it was anyways a guy was on
wendy williams and when he's telling
wendy williams when i tell you to make a
sandwich you make me a sandwich who is
that guy
i forget his name
what a great back and forth yeah when i
tell you woman when i tell you to make
me a sandwich you make me sound serious
he's being dead serious is there a woman
williams she says when i tell you to
make a sandwich a woman you make me a
sandwich like i'm not going to make you
sandwich oh okay okay let me get this
straight so if we go out to dinner do
you expect me to open the door yes when
we go out there and take care of the
bill do you expect me to pay for it yes
so when we go out there fight breaks out
and somebody says something do you
expect me to go i expect you to punch
him in the face well then when i expect
you to make me a sandwich you make me a
sandwich yeah do you agree with them i
do
i do when jen and i went on our date and
we did the 101 questions i told jen
what we went through this whole question
together because i've done this exercise
familiar with this book
the book that's the guy yeah
he crushed it when when he get but he
was in eight miles i don't know if we
can play it don't play it don't play but
this is something that uh people have to
see but anyways jen and i go to uh we go
through 101 questions and i said look uh
what what is your expectation of me boom
boom boom boom boom check check check no
problem no problem no problem no problem
here's what i expect from you i don't
care if my wife is black i don't care if
my wife is white i don't care my wife is
hispanic filipino whatever i expect her
to know how to make middle eastern food
because my mom and my dad are only going
to be here for a while you got to make
my favorite dish that i like and she's
like okay i didn't have a lot of
requests my requests were like three to
five requests for your requests
i have the book i'll bring you in one
time we'll go through the the requests
that i had but i said this is one of the
things i the number of kids i wanted to
have the role the relationship you gotta
have the support anyways i went through
but i said uh i want uh uh middle
eastern i want my wife to know how to
cook middle eastern food because if the
house smells like food kids kids will
stay home if a dozen kids will leave so
next date
she makes she goes on google makes an
assyrian dish
and i'm like it was horrible
i mean it was the worst meal in my life
but i sat there and i'm like eating the
food just to say i'm eating the food and
i told i said babe this is not good my
mom and dad can make it a million times
better but i have so much respect for
the fact that you didn't jump to and say
who am i i don't need to i'm not kidding
i'm like you know what hat's off to you
but effort but i tell you i can tell you
ten other stories where that wasn't the
case of course you're right yeah with
other women yeah like i'm not gonna do
that for you we're gonna go out there
and do this no problem by the way some
people are listening to this and they'll
say well i still don't cook and my
husband cooks no problem that's part of
your arrangement not my i'm not gonna in
our house i'm not the handyman
right yeah i'm not the handyman i'm not
the guy you know if you come to my house
and i asked senator tico the other day
we had a conversation it's like dad you
know in school we have the same name
people think when i grow up i have to be
a businessman like i said no you don't
he says well why not i said dude you're
going to be whoever you want to be i
only want to see you do what you want to
do i'm 100 support you on what you want
to do as long as you're not breaking the
law as long as you're not hurting people
i got your back he says okay he says but
no that's not how it works i'm i'm
expected to be like i said no you're not
he says so tell me why i said let me ask
you a question in the house when toys
break
how often do you guys come to me he says
daddy you have no clue how to fix toys i
said who do you go to papa he fixes all
the toys i said i can never be a
handyman like papa and i'm totally
comfortable with that we all have a
certain strength meaning there is that
understanding of what you expect from a
girl that may be different
felix is than yours let me ask this
question yeah sure bud it seems to me
that your guys are defined because
you're finding common ground here
there's not a lot that you've said that
has that have been disagreeable yes
what are the the code of conduct of the
rules like for instance
i i asked these questions on
saskatchewan on the show that i host
that you guys have been on who pays on
the first date well the man you know if
a fight breaks out you want a man to
protect you okay man hold a door
chivalry
what are the code of conduct
that women need to abide by do these
things like the sandwich example and
what are the code of conduct that men
need to bring to the table there seems
to be that the men have to do this bing
bing bing bing make more money do this
protect the household you know bring
home the bacon what are the code of
contact that men need to do and what is
the code of conduct that women need to
do and if there's an agreement here i'd
love to hear it yeah i mean the biggest
thing is that you know men have to
always bring something to the table
there is an invisible burden performance
on men to bring certain things to the
table and
in society you know applauds that yeah
man up do this other stuff but i if i
say hey well ladies we need you to do
this this and this we get a lot of
backlash for that in other words what
men want is typically almost always
demonized whereas what women want is
considered preferences but what we want
is considered discrimination so if i was
to say for example i don't want to date
no fat hoes oh my god that is so fat
shaming that's [ __ ] up but if i was to
say oh well but if a woman wants to say
i don't want no broke iron no ugly guy
or no small dick energy guy or whatever
the hell it is no one bats perfectly
it's completely it's completely socially
acceptable for yourself about it shame
men nobody wants one minute man no one's
you know yeah small dick man all that so
in other words it is okay for women to
have standards and not men and that's
what i'm saying like where guys need to
kind of come in and put standards on
women because a lot of girls just think
i'm going to show up on a date and be
pretty and that's it and i don't got to
worry about nothing else and this guy's
got to impress me and i'm telling guys
no you got to make girls perform too
because too many girls are used to
getting attention and validation for
nothing more than breathing so what do
they need to do to perform so i would
say the biggest thing is every guy is
different right they're going to have
different things but most men are easy
to please as long as a woman is
compliant submissive feminine uh
attractive pleasant to be around not
annoying like you're gonna be
have a lot of guys uh happy just with
that you know what i'm saying then every
other guy depending on what they want
you know maybe they're an entrepreneur
they're gonna need help or whatever but
a lot of women come into the
relationship thinking what can you do
for me versus what they need to do is
come into the relationship thinking what
can i do for you because at the end of
the day i think women always make the a
really bad mistake where they think oh
well i have a bunch of guys hit me up
whatever no your game is can you retain
the guy that you like in my own respect
the guy's game is can i attain the girl
the girls game is can i retain the guy
after i [ __ ] him and if you were to ask
a lot of modern day women they can't
retain these dudes that's why a lot of
them are chronically single guys ain't
[ __ ] blah blah it's because their
retention value sucks because they come
in from the perspective of let me get
what i can i'm going to come in as a
liability versus being an asset a lot of
girls are liabilities are going to be
honest so here's the biggest problem
right that i see it from the podcast
from dating actually being out there in
the field and it's scary because most
women never think about it
they know what they want
to an example six feet six inches six
figures
you know the typical the six rule top
percent guy however they never asked
question
what does that guy really want and as a
result they'll do the most oh i'm a boss
babe i have my own money i can buy a car
i can do this or not it's like no i
don't know another me i want a girl's
feminine cousins to be around is
peaceful right men want peace however
here's the thing that most women need to
understand as well
what they need to do is bring value to
the guy and it could be anything for
example let's say i don't want a pizza
shop right and for me personally all i
need is someone here on saturdays when
my staff is not available
to take phone calls
it's just really into me guess what
she's gonna say you know what damn my
man needs this on saturday i'll make
time and adjust for him because he's my
man and i care about i respect him as a
result that's adding value like for
example it could be even in the gym you
know what he needs his protein shake at
10 am she says you know what i'll wake
up early make it for him and go back to
sleep that's adding value so we're just
saying for the most part most women they
don't even care or want to know what men
want they just say i want this guy
because he's high value but it's amazing
we've we've brought girls on the show
and they'll say i want this and i want
that we actually have something called
the delusion calculator it's kind of
funny and we have
one of our supporters actually made and
he pulled stats from the u.s census
bureau and from the national health
organization right that compo has a
composite of like all the men in the
united states etc and they'll will say
okay i want a guy to be six feet tall um
uh i don't have the link here but um we
we've used it before and like
almost every time without fail when we
asked to to describe the guy from height
standpoint how much money they make
whatever they're almost always describe
a guy in the top two or three percent of
men say over six feet tall 100 000 plus
whatever and then we ask okay so this is
what you wanted the guy what do you
bring back [ __ ] crickets man they
don't really know what to say they'll go
ahead and sometimes say something like
what he was saying like oh well i bring
my own money i bring my own stuff too
and a lot of women don't understand that
attraction is not symmetrical it's
asymmetrical men and women are attracted
to completely different things a lot of
girls don't understand this which is
also scary because they think why make
my own money i'm successful i'm
ambitious blah blah blah blah that's
great that sounds great on paper for you
but men don't necessarily care about
these things and they're like what are
you talking about blah blah blah and i'm
just like well if i decided you know i'm
gonna do my nails on saturdays and wear
heels every now and then and be you know
be very pretty and stuff you look at me
like i'm crazy right yeah that's not
attractive okay well that's how i feel
every time you come up and say i'm a
boss i make this much money whatever
because whether women want to accept it
or not making money being successful et
cetera you tend to have masculine traits
when you are a go-getter and an a-type
personality and a lot of guys don't find
that attractive in the men that they're
competing for
don't find these things attractive
because once a man has money the last
thing he cares about is a girl that has
money like that if she does have it it's
a plus but it's not necessarily a
requirement pat you
you've got thousands employees uh or con
general con independent contractors that
work for you
a lot of them are couples
right some of them are single some of
these women make
hundreds of thousands of dollars have
you found that what they're saying is
accurate meaning the wit the single
women like i'm not talking about the
power couples within your company the
single women who are making quarter
million bucks and up or even 100 grand
and up are having a harder time
retaining a man
or is it
are they off
no i think it's purely
the what he's talking about makes a lot
of sense but
it's purely values and principle
i i have one of my uh one of the ladies
i used to work with
she was the type a personality in the
marriage he was not he was the passive
so if you did the star personality thing
she's probably an sa
uh [ __ ] tnr would be all the way at the
bottom one percent she was all sna okay
and he was more our personality
relationship hey love you
and maybe a little bit of s and a little
bit of tea and a little bit of a right
but she was like a powerhouse guess what
she never cooked
she never did anything but she was
pretty she took care of herself she made
the money but she also supported him and
she was the face of the business and it
worked for them because he didn't want
to be the face go-to talking about who
we just had on jedediah she's the face
of the family husband's the supporter
it's working out very well dynamics are
different the challenge when somebody uh
listens to me or listens to them or
listens to whoever that's given their
philosophy everybody thinks this is the
only way to do it it's not there's a
hundred different ways to get married
and making work but by the way there's a
hundred ways to do it the wrong way
people marry often for the wrong things
and it's just not a it's not a
attractive thing by the way i watch this
one video lady she's 60 years old and
she says uh
you know let me tell you guys about my
life in my 20s the feminist movement was
taken off i joined it i went and became
a career woman and i did so well and all
i wanted to do was be better than men be
better than this and i bought into that
philosophy today i'm a millionaire today
i'm a c-suite executive today i've been
able to have all these shares i live in
a nice house i have all this other stuff
i don't have a husband i don't have kids
because i bought into this feminism
concept and she's now living in regret
so she regrets it because the value of
life you got to invest into things that
have depth
depth is not
i met you we go home we have a good time
and then i never call you again there is
that's just a release that's just
science that's just biology but the
stuff in life that have depth
is is a lot of risk it's it's a it's
annoying it's it's challenging it
sucks your energy out of you sometimes
so you know she eventually had to figure
out for herself but it's too late for
her not necessarily is too late for
she's 60 but she definitely doesn't have
the market value
she's not having kids but she can't have
kids
so so so that's what i'm saying
sometimes the
but she bought into someone's philosophy
yeah yeah that's the problem we're
buying into someone's philosophy you
know i'm buying it you're buying it she
bought it you buy into the wrong
person's philosophy you lose your life
by the way yeah it's gone so i'll say
this right there's philosophy but also
facts and truth and at the end of the
day yes generally speaking you can't
find a way out however exceptions don't
make the rule yeah and as a result we
have to speak in generalities because
the general population they don't know
for the most part what they're doing so
just to be safe hey here's some facts
here's some data yeah you make yourself
aware and they make choice for yourself
yeah we're not seeing as to do what we
say we're just saying hey here's the
factors of data you make a choice but in
reality speaking you can see in real
time how women respond how we respond
and make yourself a decision based off
of that and we also always talk about
you know probabilities versus
possibilities and when we debate with
girls a lot of the times they're so in
the possible like yeah well it's
possible for me to find my guy and we be
a power couple and he's going to accept
me and my you know masculine attitude as
you would say when i was like yeah it's
possible but is it probable no actually
let's pull up this calculator and see
how prevalent this guy is and we pull up
the calculator and it ends up sure you
know they get this score they have a
cat-back score at the bottom all these
girls be scoring five out of five
cat-backs perfect you know what i'm
saying so it's uh as far as like the
delusion goes so like is it possible to
find this guy that's six foot three a
good looking blah blah blah is gonna be
monogamous to you whatever potentially
but is it probable no another thing too
is that um like as far as like the
dynamics you mentioned before is like
women that are power and they ha um very
strong or the face of the um business or
whatever and the husband is the
background though i've definitely seen
those you know um couples work and it
happens uh every now and then what i've
realized is that most women don't want
to be in an authority position when
they're with a man they want the man to
lead some girls are okay with it with
okay i'll lead and i'll have this guy
behind me but most girls want the man to
lead so we tell guys listen just be
comfortable being a leader because
you're going to be most attractive to a
majority women by being this way now is
there a woman out there that will be
okay with you being on the backseat
absolutely there's always those girls
there's a challenge with that here's a
challenge with it yeah sure is the
following and and adam i actually got a
question for you because there's only
one person here that has your experience
and here's what it is your experience
you've partied in multiple decades being
single so i'm curious to know what's
changed with you in a marketplace but
going back to that yeah we were talking
about what we were okay
we're talking about probability
possibility
okay so this is what's going to give you
the highest chances here's my experience
you give a guy a dating book on how to
be a player okay he reads the book on
how to be a player he reads the game
he's like oh you ain't that pretty okay
you know you know whatever it's like oh
wow you mean i'm not that pretty i've
had better than you oh my gosh well one
of the and i was like oh wow this works
you know you're calling her stuff that
kind of works man you know i hey mary
how you doing my name's not mary it's
it's oh i'm so sorry i i confuse you
with somebody else who's you you know so
that yeah you learned that stuff right
does it work not like pat has ever read
that book
exactly but but here's the point though
here's the point if you're acting
eventually people gonna know who the
real you is that's the problem so
meaning if i have to act like a gangster
but i'm a ranker i'm a i'm a you know
i'm i'm a nice
i'm not i'm not a gangster yeah then i
was going where were you bro you know
what are you talking about you ain't
that tough why acting so tough behind
closed doors so you you can only do that
if it's really you yes eventually if
you're gonna be serious with a girl
she's gonna realize you can are pretty
weak you ain't that guy so you have to
also balance that part out then the
divorce is definitely around the corner
because she married a different guy so
so for me when i went on a date uh uh
before we would act like oh my gosh
man you know what i was just walking by
smell those roses oh they smell so good
and you know i just love flowers my
favorite movie is notebook you know it's
just love story
fake fake fake fake fake fake listen
what's your favorite movie dude i
freaking love old school damn i love it
frank the tank frank the tank rank the
tank you know what are you doing
tomorrow i got to go to bed
okay you apologize to frank
you pop
so but the point is so jenna and i go on
a date yeah
and
i'm on a conference call coming back
she's listening to me on the conference
call it was probably the most heated
conference call i had and she's like
who the hell is this guy and i get off
the conference call i said listen if
we're going to have series you need to
see all sides of me this is kind of me
okay all right let me see and then boom
we have arguments first week not waiting
six months to have arguments yeah then
there's all this other stuff like who
the hell is this guy so listen i can act
but eventually i know who i am yep this
is who i am yeah do you like it if you
don't please don't fight it because this
is kind of how i'm wired and and i'm
going to get better so that's the part
where i mean what if a guy tries to act
like you but it doesn't fit it's not
going to work because it's not my run
and that goes back with what i was
saying before at the top of the show
talking about how you know your
competence leads to accomplishments
leads to confidence right and then you
got to be congruent based on that that
swagger you are right you got to be
congruent and girls are able to like i
said before they're socially very
socially receptive so they're going to
be able to tell okay this guy's faking
it after they deal with you a bit right
and that's why it's very important to be
who you are and say who are you are and
don't put on an act like i get it like
some guys have to learn attractive
traits or whatever but that's why we
tell guys become the best version of
yourself because after you become the
best version yourself you're going to be
in the best position where you're going
to be the most attractive because you're
going to be confident in yourself and
then when you deal with women they're
going to be able to feel that it's going
to radiate off you without even having
to try and then it's going to be
congruent and then you have to you don't
have to purport yourself to be somebody
that you're not it's just this is how i
am and we tell guys all the time you
need to operate with girls there is no
negotiations we don't negotiate with
terrorists it's take it or [ __ ] leave
it you know what i'm saying this is how
we operate with girls all the time we
tell them like this is how it is like we
don't negotiate women this is what i'm
doing you can come along for the ride
but i'm not following you and when i and
i know a lot of people like oh my god
that's a misogynistic oh my god it's a
woman
but what we say well the reason why we
say that is because we understand most
women not all but most women watch uh
assertive dominant man that's a leader
that knows what path he's on and she
wants to come along for the ride there's
a reason why fifty shades of grey is
like the most popular book is because
that man exemplifies so many different
attractive and arousing characteristics
that women look for and if a guy can
exemplify that and be congruent to it
you're going to be very attractive to a
lot of women and then on top of that a
lot of women find you attractive you
have a
abundance mindset your girl is going to
be in line because she's going to see
other girls looking at you we know the
importance of pre-selection when it
comes to women and i've always said it
when you have other women in line the
girl that you're with is going to get in
line and that's why it's so important to
be congruent like you were saying before
that i got a quick question for you
because of course uh you talk about the
delusional calculator i i need to get
that by the way is that an app yeah yeah
so that's the that's the one website we
have our own calculator i'll get the
link for you all and you guys can use
hilarious and i guarantee you if you
talk to patrick about the delusional
calculator especially now that he's had
a lot of success and very proud of what
he's accomplished there's probably a lot
of people that come to you just in
general and this i don't think that's
necessarily a relationship thing i think
that's a society thing uh you've played
sports you've realized that florida
state be oh i'm going to be the next
wide receiver my next neon dion i'm sure
patrick pullman comes to you i'm going
to be the next podcast person but they
haven't put the work in right you talk
about the competence you call them
accomplishments and confidence how many
times patrick in society someone's come
up to you and you're like come on
realistically like really you know i'm
saying all right i think it's really a
society thing in general man everyone
just has this perception that um you
know they're more worth than what they
really are and you keep talking about
that market value right patrick i think
i think the main thing is what they're
doing right that's working for them
gentlemen if you can get anything out of
what they're doing that's working for
them they're managing expectations up
front
the opposition either likes the
expectation or it doesn't it's not their
problem yeah it's the opposition's
problem you don't like it don't like it
you like it you like it there's there's
nothing else you can say about it
because it's my life so if somebody
comes to like tyler okay tyler why don't
you
tell us your philosophy because you
you're very upset at fresh and fit i
asked him off before you guys came in i
said so what do you think about these
guys i i don't know i don't know so so
why don't you tell us your philosophy
slightly different well so maybe i got
some of the viral clips right but
there's there's like you said there's
nothing that they've said today that
i've disagreed with at all but like i've
i've been with the same girl since i was
18. we have a kid together um like i
she's a partner of mine we i i get
better as she gets better she helps out
i pick up the slack where she can't she
picks up my slack like it's a
partnership it's something we want to
grow and foster and nurture and that's i
think
a lot of people have lost that idea that
if you want to take over the world you
don't need a boss [ __ ] or a bad [ __ ]
or whatever it is you need somebody
that's going to pick up where you
leave off and likewise and you guys can
conquer the world together that's what
they're saying as well yeah yeah they're
saying that the the bad [ __ ] is not the
model is what they're talking about they
don't want that that's what the fresh
was talking about yeah so we'll smash
them but we want to wipe them yeah while
you're single do your thing go have your
fun but again man
going back to it manage an expectation
up front 99 of relationships that i've
had that haven't worked i i'm telling
you right now the relationships that
haven't worked where it was my fault and
i look back so i only look at the stuff
that i screwed up with and i've screwed
up many of them you know what they all
have in common i did not manage
expectations up front it's my fault i
don't sit there and say what the other
person so eventually i'm like yeah this
relationship didn't work out why you
didn't manage expectations you just saw
google gaga over the fact oh my gosh
she's so hot you screwed up so rather
here's where i stand is that good if you
like it it's not going to change this is
where i stand with this and it works out
that's what i think they do right and by
the way that's how we were in the
military it was kind of like look i'm
not looking for wife i'm not looking for
this but if you want to have a good time
no problem anything outside of that i
have no desire to get married while i'm
in the army and the girl either said no
i don't like that or she said cool i
respect that great then let's go and if
it's fun we'll do it again if it's not
this will be the last time but it was
all up front managing that expectation
so how long have you been married now
patrick
twelve and a half years but you know
what i say you know what i say about
marriage what do i say about marriage
the day i got married and i'm giving a
speech at in front of our wedding i said
let me tell you something about marriage
i don't know whether we're going to be
married for 50 years
but i do know we're going to be married
for one year we're going to take it one
year at a time
i said this in front of 500 family
members
i said
we're gonna take this one year at a time
and none of you guys can create
unnecessary pressures for us because i
don't wanna say number two at my wedding
day i said do not ask my wife if she's
pregnant you're gonna have a problem
with me
nobody can ask my wife if she's pregnant
there's a lot of extra pressures for
having kids you're not going to come to
my website you guys have kids or not
when we do you'll find out about it i
want a lot of kids but if it doesn't
happen it's none of your business i
looked at both sides of the family don't
ask my wife about kids and don't ask us
about you know all this other stuff and
yeah marriage one year at a time we've
been married 12 and a half years we're
about to be 13 years i think we can make
it to 13. the reason why i say this is
the following reason some people say
he's got an agenda he's got this or he's
got that no
life changes
people change situations change i can't
control the other person i can control
myself i don't walk on water i don't
have the expectation of walking on water
my standard is not to be perfect that
standard of perfection ruins
relationship the standard of perfection
ruins relationships the standard of
perfection rules friendship all of that
so listen
here's where i am i respect you we're
gonna play the game i love you i'm gonna
protect you i'm gonna be my best but at
the same time let's take it one year out
of time it's worked out well yeah i
think the biggest thing uh that's a very
good point you made earlier um the
biggest thing for guys especially is
that like okay this is who you are right
just the core foundation is make your
money focus on your mindset your fitness
as a result you're becoming a better man
guess what if you're in the best
position possible for yourself like for
example i'm not myron my room is not me
you see flashy jewelry lifestyle that's
just me that's why i wrote right but
guess what regarding women and dating
this is who i am i'm not trying to be
somebody i'm not
likewise he's very upfront very you know
masculine very who he is but guess what
that's who he is what's the result if
you are who you are and you prove
yourself as a guy i'm telling you right
now that's all you need to do you don't
need to be me or might just be yourself
but at the same time agree yourself
mentally physically and also money-wise
yeah i don't know i don't uh this
again i thought there's going to be a
[ __ ] ton of things but but everyone
takes our clips and like oh i disagree
with this but then when you get the full
context of yourself what you're saying
is for men to be men by the way if you
want options increase your market value
you have to as simple as that like the
days of just being able to like you know
kind of have game or having like used to
be where you can have like do one thing
like well and like do really well with
it but like nowadays man with the the
pickiness of women how the mark the
dating marketplace has changed women
have more options than ever before you
really have to be a complete package if
you want to be able to get the dating
options that you want and on top of that
be able to retain girls keep them in
rotation whatever because if you got
like let's say you got game right but
you don't got any money or you don't not
the best looking guy right um you'll be
able to get girls you might get laid
once or twice here or whatever it may be
but you're not going to be able to
retain that girl long term you're going
to lose it to some dude that has this
[ __ ] together whatever maybe that might
have less game than you or let's say
you're a very good looking guy you might
get laid every now and then but you're
not able to keep girls around or take
them on dates give them a good
experience and retention goes down or
let's just say you have only money well
they're not going to respect you because
you don't understand how to
cognitively stimulate her and get her to
be aroused by you and actually genuinely
attracted she's dealing with you just as
a means to them because you have
financial stability so we tell guys you
need to be the complete package you need
to be in shape you need to have game you
need to understand female nature you
need to um
have your money on point so you can go
ahead and be the most marketable to the
largest demographic of girls there's
some girls that only want good looking
guys that are in shape cool now you're
in shape there's some girls that only
want guys that have money cool you can
get them chicks as well there's some
girls that want guys that you know have
a talking mouth talking a good talking
game cool so that way you're the most
marketable to the largest amount of
women because we tell guys all the time
in today's
dating game you got to work volume you
got to be talking to a lot of girls and
to be able to talk to the most girls and
have the highest potential of success
you have to have the most attributes
will make you attractive to the largest
demographic of women and having all
these things in place not only will make
it more attractive make you happier as a
man in general but you're going to have
an abundance mindset and you're not
going to operate from a scarcity mindset
so many guys operate where it's like oh
my god i hope you like bill she likes me
let me try to impress her i'm like no
[ __ ] that [ __ ] it's not i hope she likes
me game it's take it or [ __ ] leave it
game comply goodbye this is how i am and
when you have that abundance mindset
even if the girl doesn't like you or she
gets offended by it she's gonna respect
you and i tell guys all the time a
girl's respect is more important than
her liking you because if she respects
you she's gonna be like okay you know
what this guy isn't kissing my ass this
guy isn't all about it uh you know
putting me on a pedestal whatever this
is different this is the refreshing let
me figure out what's going on here
because most girls are used to getting
their asses kissed for nothing more than
them being of
being a female and having a vagina so
when you come in like oh no that's not
how i operate or you got to do this or
you impress me finally it puts her in a
position where she actually wants to be
in she's finally chasing a man's
validation for once and that makes you
more attractive and if it doesn't [ __ ]
her find another girl
what's you've been in at 20 some years
yes yeah okay and you've been single for
20 something you've been in
relationships and relationships yeah
yeah but yeah but we you haven't lacked
relationships but you've seen
how much of it's changed how different
is it today because i don't know what it
is to swipe right i don't know what it
is to have what do you call it online
access to all these apps that are out
there that makes it a lot easier believe
it or not does that does that mean a
guy's ability to have a mouthpiece today
doesn't matter as much as it did 15
years ago you know do you know what i'm
asking yeah yeah yeah like back in the
days like we had to go up and and you
know say lines here's what i'll tell you
with that yeah um you guys tell me
because i'm yeah yeah
i'm gonna give you guys two totally
different perspectives
i remember being in eighth grade liking
a girl and i had to call up her freaking
landline
the dad picked up the phone
i had to say hello mr so-and-so can i
speak with so and so who's this well
like i have to get through that barrier
okay do you imagine you know the
freaking balls you need to have as a 13
year old boy to get through the dad in
order to speak to the girl that's tough
in order to and that's before she even
got on the phone then i got to be able
to spit some game and then get what like
do you understand the barriers to entry
are so ridiculous insanely easy now
you need to have be able to talk you
need to have confidence you have swag
you need to have respect you need to
have just a good head on your shoulders
you need to understand the way today you
do no no back there oh yeah yeah now you
could be a [ __ ] schmuck
slide into a girl's dm with a sup girl
you up like
and a girl will respond
like the game that you need to have back
then is so much stronger than it is
today now with that being said
it's so much easier now you can go on
any different app you can go on
instagram you can go on anywhere and you
can start you know making your move and
the and the the the last thing i'll say
is
here's what i will say
what i've learned in my 20 years i've
okay i've been partying in south beach
for 20 years
college after college now in my early
40s
when you're in your 20s you're focused
on your boys
okay the boys want to have a good time
we're going out so
in your 30s now all your friends are
getting married you're focusing on the
girls perspective you're putting
yourself in the girls shoes
the most liberating thing now is being
40 you know when you're and you're like
all right
you focus on yourself and this is
basically what you're talking about
you're not worried about your boy's
opinion you're not worrying about
appeasing any particular female or like
trying to
you know be someone you're not
the the realest thing you could be is is
who you are and be what you want and
then
from there what do you call it hold
frame and say now this is what i look
for this is what i want and if you can't
reach that oh good i don't want to waste
your time the number one thing is not
being able to waste time i'd rather
invest my time than spend time anyway
okay so i'll break it down right because
we're in the game right now and it's
funny because a lot has changed since
you know you were back in the day now as
you know
and my opinion our opinion is the
biggest thing now in the world is
instagram yep because guess what
celebrities influencers athletes
stars movie stars right guess what those
platforms and girls are actively on
these platforms every single day guess
what i can have a girl in idaho
tennessee i don't know alaska right i
got in the damn say yo kind of miami
guess what first floor oh she's in miami
but
here's the problem right back in the day
they didn't have that because if you're
in those states or you're in these
cities no one knew who you were when
people around you will actually see you
in real life now because of social media
the climate has changed i could see him
and go anywhere in the world and get her
here so picture this right
as easy as the dml you said earlier i
could send it to her today and if you're
verified even better because guess what
now you're a valid uh person of i want
to say um status status right so
regarding brand awareness having a brand
and being that guy now on social media
you win so look for example i stutter a
lot right i'm not really the most i want
to say uh talk to this person because
i don't thought that much but my brand
awareness is on point because my
lifestyle what i do and then for example
just me being a social media presence
guess what that's enough for me to get
what i want as a result this might be a
little controversial i used to date
three or three girls a day so literally
wake up at like um at 8 am go to work
lunch time i'll go on like a little date
and then afterwards i'm going to date
again and then at night but guess what
over social media i'll be at home on my
instagram senator damn yo what are you
doing tonight on free cool uh link up or
for example hey what do you do during
the day link up and it's that easy now
here's the problem right with this much
access and options it's hard to say you
know what damn i'm gonna be with this
girl because she's these these are
traits because there's so many girls now
you could hit up it's like yo why settle
for one
however i'll say this regarding this
whole lifestyle being a player all
options
is it fulfilling no because
at the end of the day i've realized from
experience the best thing you can do as
a man
is show your time someone you care about
and actually want to be around because
all these girls will yeah you could
smash whatever have that experience but
in reality speaking how not one person
you connect with physically spiritually
mentally that's important over
everything but regarding the data
marketplace yeah it's super easy
nowadays all right so i'm very
disappointed that you went that deep in
the relationship
you got me emotional right now you're
making me want to watch notebook and
fall in love
very sweet i was taking some notes on
this so like this is this is kind of
this is this is the the current dating
marketplace right now at a glimpse right
so like
if you got this cup right right so let's
pretend that this is a woman's
validation meter right so it used to be
where a woman had to go outside right to
be able to get attention and or
validation from men right she didn't
have the advent of the smartphone and
all this other stuff she had to go
outside and or put herself in a position
going to nightclubs be social whatever
to get attention from men so men's
attention was not as easy to gain as it
is nowadays right so that club that when
she walks outside the house the cup is
empty right because now she's got to go
out there and get her ego pulled or
whatever and get brought up but nowadays
thanks to social media by the time she
steps out the house this cup is full
with validation because she opens up her
instagram she has a bunch of dms she
opens up her dating apps has a bunch of
options and what happens is they start
to have an abundance mindset and i
always say women naturally have an
abundance mindset men have to earn their
abundance mindset so just by a girl
existing looking at her phone whatever
it may be i know girls that will turn on
their tinder i've seen it before on
tick-tock as well turn on their tinder
get a bunch of matches not go on a date
when you them and then just close it
down just to get their validation just
to get like th that value feel good
about themselves
because women
whether they want to admit or not
they're they have a lot of them have low
self-esteem there's a reason why the
makeup industry is never going to go out
of business why hair salons nail salons
even during a pandemic they were still
in business to some degree because women
understand that their primary agency
comes from the way they look looks right
so getting attention from men reconfirms
in their mind i'm pretty i can still get
a guy because a woman's value is based
on her beauty i don't care what none of
them save and the strongest most
independent woman is going to wear heels
and makeup and lipstick right so
they had to actually go out to get this
validation
nowadays thanks to social media dating
apps whatever women get this attention
to validation without having to do
anything besides be at home and i didn't
experiment on this right so a couple
years ago i released a dating course
with my with my buddy and when i was
doing the testing right we used to
tender teach you guys how to use tinder
sugar apps whatever it may be when i was
doing the testing to see which uh you
know the best way to get matches and
everything else like that see how the
algorithm goes i had two phones i did an
a b test right so on one phone i
basically did a boost right on all the
accounts on another one i made a fresh
account didn't do no boost right and i
turned the phones off for about 24 hours
turn it back on and both phones have a
bunch of notifications right and i'm
like oh yeah this is [ __ ] awesome
this is great i'm like yeah i'm getting
his attention whoo you know then hit me
imagine getting this amount of attention
every single day for nothing more than
the fact that i'm alive it would
probably make me a piece of [ __ ]
wouldn't it and then i realized like
damn wait hold on this is what a lot of
modern day girls go through every single
day and the studies show it like women
find most men almost over 90 of men on
tinder and bumble all these sites as
unattractive below average and
unattraction most women don't match with
and or look at profiles unless the guy's
in the top five percent of of dudes um
one in three men right now is either a
virgin and or sexually enacted between
18 to 30. so it's become harder for a
majority of men to get girls with the
new social media age because women have
more options than before and a girl that
would have been uh you know constrained
to her own sexual marketplace let's say
she lived in iowa whatever maybe idaho
right she had that area and we talked
about this in deep with royal tomasi it
was a localized sexual marketplace but
now with the internet dating et cetera
she can go and talk to someone in miami
she can go ahead and talk to someone in
l.a and there's a lot of girls flying
out all over the place because now they
have access to men that they would have
never otherwise had so in other words
when they wake up this glass is full
every single day which is why a lot of
guys are invisible to most women right
so and this is because you know dating
apps and instagram in general so what's
basically happened now is that
the top men
right are getting a majority of the
girls
right the majority of girls are chasing
a very small select men and with the
advent of the internet it's become even
more pronounced and women have become
even more selective because
with them getting a validation that they
get on their phones they're like [ __ ]
this i can i'm getting hit up by a
future i'm getting hit up by whatever a
girl literally came on our pod and
talked about yeah i banged future and he
just did me and he was gonna give me a
family but it didn't end up happening
but this is this right the rapper yeah
they're wrapping it up on the air yeah
it's on our show okay they know they
know what time it is but like but that's
that's that's the dating marketplace
we're in average women now right have
access to top tier guys and that's just
what happens so like a regular one fresh
goes on a date with three girls a day
yeah he's coming here taking it so so
it's basically long story short a lot of
guys are struggling because women have
higher uh higher standards now and male
attention is worth nothing nowadays so
in other words the dating sites made the
rich richer the poor poorer yes yes yes
it's like stimulus interesting yo you
know the scary part you got it there's a
darker side to this dark you want to go
there girl
yeah
you know what i'm gonna say right
trigger
so
guys nowadays right girl scout have a
boyfriend a sneaky link a guy that they
just [ __ ]
and what do you call it a sneaky link
like you know late night hit him up
sneaky link i'll come over and would you
smash and then you go back home to your
boyfriend whatever that's what it is and
then the third one they might have the
trigger daddy so the whole culture now
is okay cool how do i get these things
in life without working for it for girls
and what's the best way sugar daddy i
just show up look pretty
i might [ __ ] or not but i'm gonna get my
rent paid i'm gonna get either a new car
or i'm gonna get money to go shopping or
just have fun and think about it right
who are sugar babies nowadays girls in
college i have no money it could be even
a boss made that just wants a better man
and it's funny because a lot of girls
will say i won't be caught down on
tinder or bumble because that's below me
but i'll be on the trigger site waiting
to find the right i gotta take care of
me and as a result guess what now from
that experience they expect all men to
be on a level so the average girl that
you see you're not you're going next
door right you know she's cute pretty
she's very to herself whatever you don't
know she might have two sugar daddies
now paying for her lifestyle you come
talk to her hey suzy i wanna take you
out [ __ ] who are you because guess what
you're not on his level and as a result
it's good no because once again social
media it could be a guy under that high
profile it could be a trigger daddy you
never know who you're competing with so
we say for most guys
on some level become the best version of
yourself because at that point you could
kind of play the game but even then you
may not because if they're millionaires
they're sugar daddies you never really
know so as a result most men will never
get the option or even the chance to
play the game of the dating and the
scary part is a lot of guys don't even
know what they're up against in in the
current dating marketplace is to like
why it's so competitive so what i've
always said like feminism what it's
inadvertently done it's it's actually
given all the leverage to the top five
percent of men yeah because what happens
is a woman earns a gets her own career
makes more money becomes successful well
now a large pool of candidates that
would have been a great husband and a
potential boyfriend this guy doesn't
mean but they're going to be factory
yeah they want to date their equals
exactly right so women we know women on
a bounce probabilities do not date below
their social economic status they want
to at least bare minimum where they're
at or preferably above so as women make
more money and become more successful
now their pool of men drops down with it
and they want to date up so it's given
the leverage inadvertently to a lot of
the the higher status men these women
that that fresh was talking about um how
does it affect their psychic because you
said something very profound earlier you
said
you know fast money comes slow problems
yeah so break down that mindset
um so a lot of so there's a lot of women
out there they're like i'm independent i
don't need no man i get my own money the
boss [ __ ] thing yeah like
okay how are you getting that money so a
lot of you're a career woman a but maybe
you're
more that sugar daddy with three
boyfriends type yeah and i don't think
guys understand like if you see a bad
trick on instagram or she's very
attractive you best believe bro that
she's getting crazy offers she's getting
rappers interrupt sugar daddies whatever
it may be like i always tell guys if you
guys really want to see the dating
marketplace if your friends don't buy a
hot chick ask her us here instagram and
look at her dms you guys gonna see what
i'm talking about or look at her dating
inbox or her dating profile inbox or
whatever slice she has a lot of girls
live a double life where they're whether
they're on only fans they're selling
feed pictures they're on snapchat
premium they have a sugar daddy they're
getting flown out by a certain guy or
whatever a lot of attractive women have
this thing going on they're obviously
not going to have are they all ending up
in dubai exactly what i'm saying or it's
a chick that's like you know like what
the hell you you were you're r.a at the
st school how are you a [ __ ] ireland
right now and then going to dubai after
like so a lot of girls live this double
life thanks to the internet whatever it
may be so i always say you know um fast
money comes with slow problems a lot of
girls that do you know they're strippers
only fans whatever they'll make this
money up front or sell fee picks or
whatever they'll make this money upfront
but what they don't realize is that's
going to have dire consequences on them
in the future when it comes to marriage
and or some kind of stable relationship
because we know how men are men are very
territorial women if you are about a
married chick and she's your girl and
you find out that she did some fuckshit
in the past you're more than likely
going to call off the wedding because
men have a serious point of issue with a
woman's past i always say women want a
man with a future a man wants a woman
that doesn't have a past and that's just
the way it's always been the beginning
of time men are very territorial so a
lot of girls what they don't realize is
they're doing this stuff right and they
kind of know subconsciously is going to
mess me up in the future but if it ever
comes out they don't care it's going to
mess with them and some don't even care
they're just like i'm just going to be a
daddy i don't care except me how i come
but it fast money a lot of time does
come with slow problems which is going
to be being able to find a guy we know a
big predicator on female happiness and
fulfillment typically comes from a
family and children not necessarily a
career making money hey fresh and fit i
got a quick question for you guys so um
you've talked about kind of this change
the dynamic that's happened in america
so just to let you know about me just in
general like i was you 18 years old i
was single i was with patrick from fort
campbell we you know the stories we
could tell are crazy but you know i went
on a run for 10 years kind of kind of
hear your story right you know what i'm
saying kind of going to figure out until
i met my wife and i've been married for
19 years you know things have changed
right yeah i mean i'm not going to ask
patrick this too at the same time i mean
could you imagine if we had all this
technology you know this resources
it really is scary it really is and so
for the other demographics i'm sure you
have uh males from all you know sorts of
age groups i'm probably sure in youngers
the 20s or 30s maybe even the 40s and
above that like if something were to
happen like
life has changed you know i'm a house
cat you know felix the cat house cat
you're like you're gonna throw me back
out there yeah it's almost in
are they inspiring you is this no no no
it's just it's just
listening to the same please get felix
off the podcast
but i will say my wife definitely
compliments me like you were saying you
know kind of the weaknesses were being
you know my strengths and vice versa so
that's what makes us work and it's a
different definition like you said i
think our society has it where you have
to do it this way like patrick said or
the bible says this or he says that and
i make my own rules right just society
does have laws and rules but at the same
time too yeah i have my own rules of how
i perceive my happiness tell me what
makes me happy so i definitely love you
know your perspective i think sometimes
maybe like you said you know get those
clips tyler was talking about that kind
of get lost in this of course right i
think you had lagoyavich on here just a
couple of weeks ago and he said the same
thing they were taking snippets of of
his conversations and then changing the
the verbiage around to fit their crazy
yeah and a lot of people do that with
our content that's easy to do when you
have a longer form content oh my god we
have so many crazy things that they say
like i'll be making a point like that's
oh that's why i'm gonna clip that and
you know go viral but yeah i would say
like with the you know with the way you
know online dating is expanded and um
dating apps and instagram etc it's
really put women in the position of
advantage when it comes to dating women
have all the leverage in dating nowadays
i would say right and that's why i
always say guys you know your your game
is the guys to attain the girl her game
is the woman is to retain you after she
[ __ ] but a lot of girls don't
understand this they think well i have
even more suitors in my inbox i got all
these guys coming after me but they
don't realize that those guys just want
sex but a lot of girls conflate sexual
attraction where relationship attraction
that's a fatal flaw a lot of modern
women make as well and would you
honestly say that's like a vicious cycle
because that makes it worse like you
said the rich get richer and the poor
get poorer yeah because guys are going
to get pissed off now and say damn man i
i really think i'm a great guy i'm
pretty marketable you know i know i'm
not a 10 but i'm a i'm a 700 there's a
big divide what's happening here like
myron said earlier where the top percent
of guys are getting all the action and
the guys in the middle are kind of
squeezing like oh wait why won't you
talk to me like what's going on is
because guess what they had a taste of
the high life or they want a taste of it
and as a result you can't provide that
so they don't they want to give you a
chance i've always said it like it's
very difficult for women to regress from
a relationship standpoint once you deal
with a certain caliber of man it's like
oh man can i go back to dating an
average guy we've had girls come on the
body like yeah i've dealt with a rapper
or celebrity whatever it is athlete
whatever excuse their their perception
and the reality of what kind of man they
can actually attract because they think
well i [ __ ] this guy i hung out with
him for a weekend this is a caliber man
that i should be able to get all the
time and they don't realize no you he
was just smashing you it's not that
serious but girls will hold on to that
be like this is the caliber man i
deserve now myron crazy question for you
guys yes crazy question fast forward
10 20 years you're grown up you get
married you have kids let's say you both
have two daughters oh god okay that's a
curse yeah well pat has two boys two
daughters abortion
let me tell you karma's a [ __ ] and i
can see you both having some daughters
i'm just letting putting that out there
yeah hopefully they're healthy and
beautiful and amazing
i want to hear the advice that you would
tell your daughters
break your question
so honestly speaking
now fresh if you need to take a second
bro and take a sip of water go ahead
but i wanted the advice that you would
tell your daughters
man okay so
don't be a hoe you want the truth uh i
want it all right get as graphic and as
insightful as you possibly can i wish
you're a boy but let me not start there
um no because
damn it man no you go first
i would tell her like a lot of the
things i tell the girls on a pod you
know like understand that your past
defines you as a woman unfortunately
that's just the way it is like you know
men do care about the carfax you know
you want to mail the future he's going
to want a woman that doesn't have a pass
so that she doesn't [ __ ] up his future
and that's just the way men are
especially a guy that's worth a damn
he's going to have a lot of stake in
your past so that's number one uh you
know i would tell her go to school and
obviously get your career and everything
else like that but understand that
you know you also need to pay take that
same vigor and apply it to finding the
right guy and i would be involved in in
her finding a guy as well i think that's
a big mistake that a lot of women make
is that they don't involve you know i
always say to really get the best um how
do i to find the best guy you need a
male on your team right that has your
best self-interest no not a guy friend
that's trying to smash you that's on the
side like your dad your brother someone
that is related to that doesn't have a
sexual interest in you that actually
likes you for you and loves you for you
the closest to un you know um to ideal
love and they will tell you this guy
isn't where [ __ ] this guy isn't worth it
whatever and a lot of girls don't
involve their brother or their or their
father because you know it's awkward or
i don't want him involved whatever and
then they're picking the [ __ ] boys i
don't want to take them seriously
because women run off emotion this guy
makes me feel a certain way so i'm going
to deal with him even though he's a
terrible example so uh or a terrible uh
potential mate so i would be involved in
that i would also let her know the
uncomfortable reality is that yo your
past does matter your career doesn't
matter that much as well as well like
you know you can go to school and
everything to be sufficient but
understand that that's not going to make
you more marketable or attractive to a
man you know and i'll just give her the
uncomfortable realities about men and
women are very different i think we live
in a world now where we tell young girls
whatever taste of career you're the same
as a man you can do anything a man can
do well obviously we know that's not
true because when a transgender man
enters ncaa as a swimmer now he's a
champion he was ranked 400 some and now
he's beating the [ __ ] out all these
girls it's like men and women are not
the same we're different at certain
things men excel certain things women
excel certain things and for you to use
a male metric of success is going to
make you miserable long-term how about
you yeah so definitely um i'll tell you
the truth you know because i don't lie
to her i'll give her two options if you
want a man here's what you do if you
want to be a whole it's what you do as a
result i can't force her to be what
she's going to be she's going to choose
you know on her own but i'll say this
i'll tell you look at in the day men
want sex
but what do you want do you want a
family or do you want to be you know
flying out here doing your thing as a
result choose the path you want to take
and and i'll just say this as well
you're gonna get you're gonna get [ __ ]
over however how you react to it is
gonna determine you know what you do for
example some girls will get heartbroken
and they go on a spiral where they go
like [ __ ] every every guy they see
because they're just mad or whatever
yo at this point what do you really want
daughter do you want to be uh successful
do you want to be with a man you want to
have magic kids follow that path so
but most women when they're
you know
look the girls that are 21 to 24 they
operate completely differently from the
girls who are 27 to 32. yeah totally
like it's not even close
so
they're having fun yolo and then there's
a girl it's that other thing it's like
okay you know i need to slow down and
find a guy yeah see here's problem right
you can tell your daughter what to do
but bro when it comes to like what she
sees in front of her bro
like nigga's got game nigga's got money
[ __ ] lifestyle
that program you give to her this for a
period of time once you get certain age
is like oh this is fun my friends are
doing it i'm gonna have fun and live my
lifestyle yolo now pat you've got four
kids i assume the conversations you have
with the boys are gonna be different
than you're gonna have with the girls i
mean santa's five
brooklyn's a baby but
walk us through how you're processing
this as a father it's a risk i mean you
just have to know you're facing a risk
you know when you were talking about
you're calling 13 years old the dad's
picking up if a 13 year old guy calls me
out to want to talk to the girl
i'm calling sammy the bullets
you know i need a favor but no uh all
jokes aside i think the dynamics varies
based on who's the oldest and the
youngest let me explain if you got a boy
first
and then you have a girl
and the age difference you have uh two
examples two layers of security if you
got two boys and then you have two girls
you now have three layers of security
for the girls which is the oldest and
the young so like for example tico is
not that protective tico's personality
is more chill
with how he is all this but dylan dylan
is the dylan's going to be like you do
something to senna you're going to
you're going to have to deal with dylan
and dylan's got to have a different
personality but at the same time he gave
very good advice he said
someone's gonna screw you over then what
are you gonna do because it's gonna
happen right it's gonna happen what are
you gonna do when somebody screws you
over your boyfriend does this to you
you're gonna go on revenge and
go hook up with every single one of her
friend one of his friends and trying to
get back at him is that what you're
gonna do because that's when you really
learn it is going to take place to you i
think the other part you got to think
about as well as your values and
principles and how you treat the mom the
way you treat the mom she's watching and
the way you treat her she's going to
think that's how i want to be treated
one day because odds are my dad my
daughters are probably one of them is
going to date a guy like me and if they
date a guy like me and i know who i am
i i know that dynamics of how he's going
to want to be leading that family and
she's going to watch you see here's how
you take care of mom here's how i want
him to take care of me as well those
dynamics gonna be you can say whatever
you want manual book
28 keys to be in this and that she's
listening to nothing facts and she's
just watching to what you're doing
period she's gonna duplicate and go
after the way you live your life uh that
example is gonna do more more for you
than having her you know i'll say this
22 books girls on the show that have a
better grasp on like dating and what
they really want from imagine kids their
father was a good example to them and
that's what they saw now what did they
do your daddy issues what they saw so
that does help in terms of getting them
not directed guys are so important man
yeah it's it's amazing how like dads are
not respected in the western journal oh
you don't know man i don't need kids
like i would say a strong dad will keep
a girl off a shirt pull and son's out of
jail yep you know your dad is the first
line of defense to keep you from
becoming a degenerate to society well he
said the main job of a man is to keep
his daughter off the pole yeah yeah
means i have a father mission number one
and and patrick uh no lie i remember
this story way back when uh his his
daughter or my daughter's sister sister
paulette he said uh hey my sister
paulette's gonna visit potentially this
that the other i'm like oh you got a
sister
right and swigs patrick was like listen
man i'm gonna tell you this you're my
brother and i love you you do anything
or look in the wrong direction of my
sister you're gonna have to deal with me
so i can imagine you know tico or dylan
would be the same thing so those layered
defense i definitely know he's not lying
without saying that one day she'll tell
some of the stories publicly and you're
going to crack up with some of the
stories of what happened with her
boyfriend's one time she was dating this
one guy
and she told she the guy told her you
know what she wanted to hear which is i
love you okay
and then he screwed up royally
well he went to world's gym which one of
my friends was working out there and my
friend knows that guy who the guys and i
said listen if you guys see him in the
street i don't care where you are beat
the living [ __ ] out of this guy and i
rarely say that word on podcast
but he went there it was a bad setting
for him the guy was walked out he had a
bad situation never went back to the gym
never went back to that gym again and
then we had a christian my i come back
for christmas this is when my i was bad
at that time i was not in a good manner
you knew me at that 18 18
we go to church my dad's i want you to
go to syrian church i'm not going to
syrian church he said i want you to
dress in your military uniform and come
to church i'm wearing my greens okay
and i go to church paulette's standing
right here he shows up
damn
he shows up so my dad at this point is
like
he says you can't do anything everybody
i said that that's not that's not how
wide he says you can't do anything i
said that's somehow what he's saying
i'm at church
he says you can't do anything promise me
that's my present that's why you're here
i said that i can't i'm not wired like
that you can't he shows up
so the brother first shows up his name
is his similar name is me and then he
shows him i'm just holding him and i'm
just pulling him inside i'm pulling this
and i whisper something in his ears and
then he walked out here's the craziest
thing nine years later i recruit him to
be an agent paula recruiter not even
kidding with you wow 11 years ago and
i'm training
and i'm 32 years old he's sitting in
front of me
i'm like
what the what are you doing here
he says hey bro i said dude it was a
long time ago how are you doing how you
feeling he says uh just amanda i just
remember i said now we're cool man i
gave him a hug it was a very unique
situation
but you know there's there's a dynamic
of sister where you have to protect and
you got to teach the kids that they have
to know that but it's a sensitive topic
when you have girls and no matter what
you do you ain't god you're not around
them they're going to make a lot of
noise i will say this because i have a
younger sister and she was the girl when
i was a senior and she was a freshman
all the boys yo adam's sister like yeah
oh man if you tell a girl
you can do whatever you want just don't
do this one thing she's gonna do that
that is exactly
what the girl will do yep i had i had um
my friend jenny she was on the show
her older brothers would tell her these
are the guys that you cannot date she
goes i dated every single one of them of
course there's something in a female i
don't know it's human nature you tell
someone don't put your hand on the stove
it'll burn it don't it's not they're
gonna put their hands it's both man
they're gonna put their hand on how we
are but go back in time adam and eve
what was the one thing she can't do
don't eat the apples
i knew there was a pastor in this guy
listen the more i listen to fresh this
guy's like a closet pastor about to be
you know he's gonna run one of the
biggest churches five thousand members
you see him on stage pbd exclusive i was
actually gonna be a pastor in canada
so funny story man
i didn't even know that
so my my my grandmother's heavy in the
church um i get out not so much and
every every sunday i'll go to church i
was in a christian school and i was
raised to be you know this you know good
guy generous guy long story short i was
trying to figure out what i wanted to do
in my life i got into a really bad
mostly motorcycle accident and um
my grandma said hey you know what maybe
you should be a pastor and i'm like i
haven't tried that let me give it a try
so i'm learning how to be a pastor i'm
going to stay in school going to like
you know classes and stuff like that and
there's a program where you can go to
canada for i think a period of months
and then you become a pastor and i was
like you know what
come to miami or become a pastor
i thought about it yeah i can't keep
this canvas cold there's no girls no
lifestyle i'm gonna be teaching people
about god
uh what did i choose my lifestyle our
pastor yeah i chose miami yeah that's
crazy well i'm right there with you
because my mom to this day thinks i'm
going to be a rabbi so wow
why aren't you arriving ma it's not it's
going to happen let me let me read this
story i think this story has a little
bit to do with and by the way we
appreciate you for being vulnerable and
emotional here on the podcast
[Music]
yeah you know new international version
bible for the guy as a gift so here's a
story from uh uh good man project women
are not choosing bad men men are
choosing to be bad okay i like steve
harvey i like him as a person as a
character but as a dating coach i don't
know i watched a clip of him from last
youtube on youtube but on it a young
woman expressed she was struggling to
find a good man steve harvey solution
well why don't you stop dating bad ones
the advice was so brilliant i started
sharing the kind of wisdom with men
when they complain about their dating
woes with women oh she cheated on you
well why did she date a cheater oh the
woman you ask out won't date you maybe
stop asking out women who aren't
attracted to you somehow the men got
angry about the dating advice they found
that it's kind of dismissive and
thoughtful thoughtless off the guys i
fell in love with of the guys i fell in
love i don't regret dating them and i
probably would love would fall in love
with the similar man the future i didn't
date the abuse of lie or the guy who
didn't understand sexual boundaries i
did that anyways so the moral of the
story is the following so i is is the
idea of dating a bad guy like man i'm
attracted to these guys
is that what they're looking for and is
that what they marry hmm
um from a pastor why don't you take the
lead first i'm not a pastor bro
pastor dory chilly this but uh i'll say
this
so
bad woman
bad men right
we want what we want however there are
some key things that we've been
attracted to and these traits some of
these bad guys have
and let's be real here right there's not
really a lot of men today these guys are
just wake up go with the flow they're
not really being men so as a result most
masculine men are guys that are like bad
boys outlaws guys that are doing like
crazy stuff and let's get turned on by
that it's the truth no matter how you
look at it you can tell them hey you
know what this guy's good for you he's
going to take care of you now i want a
guy's going to have i'ma have fun with
have a good lifestyle so as a result
what am i gonna naturally go towards
those guys now regarding um
bad guys
i would say guys who they are and
they'll let you know up front so you're
choosing a bad guy
you literally know what you get into but
guess what their emotions what they
think is possible how they can change
the guy they'll give it a shot and as a
result they go into these bad scenarios
and then they say oh he hurt me but you
saw the red flags at the very beginning
but guess what he looks good he's tall
he's uh crazy i'll give it a shot i
might be able to change him
but you were saying about being you know
a bad guy i mean isn't it easier to be a
bad guy than it is to be a good guy i
mean if you're a good guy you're going
to school you're working out you're
working on your your career and stuff
like that you know you're spending time
uh you know maybe if you're a single
father or something like that with your
kids i mean that is something that's
considered you know honorable and
something that you're doing but to be a
bad guy just be a jerk and you know
don't even have any thought process i
mean what do you think about that as far
as i mean adam you're single you can
comment on that
well the uh
what they're talking about is about i
think there's three types of guys when
it comes to cheaters there's number one
serial cheaters they just they don't
whether they're upfront about it whether
they're it's hidden whether they're like
look i'm a polygamist i'd like multiple
chicks or whether they're just like kind
of do it in secret so that's number one
that's the serial cheater then there's
the number two there's the opportunist
well look i wasn't planning on cheating
but i'm here at a you know at a business
trip
in vegas and some chicks talking to me
and it's like
well you know what is it exactly whoops
how that you know
different area codes whatever it is you
know so that's an opportunist and then
there's the number third the number
three person it's like i would never
yeah i would never and then that that
person i would never when they meet that
opportunity it's whether they will yeah
or they won't yeah so that's how i kind
of define most men but it's um
most men are in that number two category
they're not complete
scumbag cheaters you know liars and
they're not
100 i'll always be faithful the rest of
my life they're opportunists and if the
opportunity
meets and you know a woman and
the thing is is is that
so there's attractive guys and there's
arousing guys and the thing is is that a
lot of women are really focused on the
arousing guys especially when they're
younger and more attractive and they can
actually negotiate for these higher
status men that are actually arousing
because the thing is is that as women
make more money and become more
successful and have their own career
they don't necessarily care about
provisioning as much especially when
they're younger and more attractive it's
like okay does this guy do it for me
does he arouse me does he do it for me
like mentally and unfortunately the
things that make you arousing to a woman
a lot of the times also are terrible
traits to have when it comes to a
long-term relationship you know you're
not being non-committal you're not
showing her that much attention you're
treating her like crap you're putting
her like on the six on your party list
everything else and these things make
you arousing to women because women
respect men that don't necessarily chase
their validation and the woman has to
chase their validation and that's for
you as a guy that's exactly where you
want to be you always want the girl
chasing you feeling like she's getting
the best deal because that's what's
going to keep her and check that's going
to
give her
keep her giving you the best um
treatment not cheating on you not doing
stupid [ __ ] because she's like damn okay
i'm fighting to get this guy i know he
has other girls this is what arouses me
but from like a relationship standpoint
it's terrible here's the problem women
are slaves to their emotions if a guy
makes her feel a certain way
right and takes her through the
emotional rollercoaster she's going to
go ahead and side with that guy so the
thing is is that a lot of girls
i'm just going to be honest don't like
to take accountability for the type of
men that they pick and i tell girls all
the time if you're going to date a man
that's attractive tall has money
whatever be prepared to share him but a
lot of sexually i mean and a lot of
girls don't want to hear that no i want
him to be monogamous to me men ain't
[ __ ] blah blah blah why can't he just be
loyal men male loyalty and female
loyalty is completely different male
loyalty is he going to protect you in
times of danger is he going to provision
for you is he going to take care of you
female loyalty is sexual fidelity but
when again well going back to how women
think men and women are the same they
think well you should also exercise
sexual fidelity uh no men and women are
different for a guy
right we show our loyalty differently
than you do you show your fidelity by
not [ __ ] other people i show my
fidelity by being willing to die and
protect you right but a lot of girls
don't understand and they don't like it
and i've always said it as a man goes up
and up the socioeconomic totem pole the
rare the more wherever catch he is the
higher the likelihood he's gonna cheat
on you and it's kind of this this
delicate balance that girls don't
understand is a catch-22 you are going
to become a slave to the very man that
you want but you don't have any
negotiating power that's nothing women
forget too is that as you go up with the
totem pole as a woman you lose leverage
you're not able to control this guy the
same way but here's the problem that's
women are arrived by uh aroused by they
want a guy that they can't control but
then they get mad when they don't have
the control but then they come and run
it back to him that's why toxic guys do
so well because women can't necessarily
control them but that guy can control
our emotions
but men also have
some sort of epiphany moment like let's
take a look at the george clooney's of
the world or even the leonardo dicaprio
or the derek jeters they're
you know there's there's
there's baseball diamonds you know
you've seen this thing the derrick derek
jeter's hit list and it's like
so and so in left field and halle berry
in center field and uh you know the name
after name after name model after model
but at some point even a man will say
look
i've had enough yeah but here's the
thing they'll say i've had enough and
they'll get a girl and take her
seriously for a while they'll be their
main chick but i've always said it high
status men nine out of 10 times are
gonna [ __ ] other girls regardless like a
lot of the times are there guys that are
gonna be monogamous for sure but out of
possibility if i lined up 100 high-value
men that have options whatever athlete's
slept whatever it may be i would argue
probably 95 of them are going to go out
and smash other chicks on the side these
are giving our computers uh women yeah
yeah i mean it's a who's who
and i think women don't understand and
or like that when i tell them that if
you're gonna have a high value man
you're not gonna have them to yourself
he's gonna exercise options to have sex
with other girls so just make peace with
it in your mind that you are going to
like it's great you have this high
status guy that's that's your boyfriend
but he's also gonna have sex with other
girls and that's not that big a deal
honestly like sex is not that big a deal
for men it's like taking a piss patrick
yeah i know so he's telling the story
it made me think about something we were
hanging out with seattle supersonic
players okay
years ago i'm talking i'm 25 years old
and they're telling stories
and
he says let me tell you what the life is
like what's the life like you know sean
kemp
gary payton let me tell you what the
life is like you go through here's this
city here's that city here's this city
here's this city here's that city and i
said so i got a question for you what's
that
why do nba players get married
why if you're a star what are you
getting married for
if if you're a hollywood star what are
you getting married for in your 20s if
you're a
actor actress what are you doing getting
if you're a star and you got a limelight
on you
the idea of you getting married man
again this is my opinion that number
needs to probably start with a four not
even a two not even a three it's
probably more closer to four when we
were in the military like why are you
getting married in the military it's not
a good idea to get married in the
military why you gotta go deploy for 18
months yep what do you think you're
doing you're going to come back with a
popeye forearm on this side like oh look
at this guy
look a freaking bodybuilder you know the
vision of that yeah so no so so what do
you what does that happen 18 months like
so don't get married in the military
three deployments oh yeah three
deployments what do you think happens in
a situation like that i think you got a
uh
you gotta have a system for yourself as
you get bigger uh one of the best things
i um
look i've been married 12 and a half
years shooting you look at my instagram
it's as if being married is a bigger
target and being single you know being
married it's more interest because can i
break you can i do this there's a target
for that right for sure and your
supporting cast is number one not saying
what the third guy says because you're a
bigger like that guy right there with
the force
yeah
so so but this is what i was going to
tell you is the supporting cast here's
how our supporting cast works i read a
book one time from billy graham this is
back in the days and 60s 70s 80s when
all these pastors having stories with
girls
left and right and he's like wait a
minute what the hell you guys doing so
billy graham said listen when we travel
we share rooms he says i used to do with
one of our guys he says now when i
travel we have to be in a room with
three of us
you're like why would you do three why
not just have a buddy he says because
when it's just you and a friend you can
convince your friend listen no one's
gonna know yeah he says but when there's
three of you one is gonna say no guys we
can't yeah yeah yeah there'll be one
voice of reason yeah he says one time
they went into hotel room he says a girl
was waiting in the room half naked he
says we just ran out
he said we left it or we just ran out
because you know that's how stories are
written so you got to be careful
nowadays there's a target on everybody
and the more you said you can't be a
target the bigger of a target you really
are does that make sense yeah yeah but
maurice oh it'll never happen to me oh
really oh you're mr perfect no problem
here's 88 people that are going to try
and watch what they can have and that's
why uh my bad boys are so attractive so
it's funny i made an instagram post
right it's
clearly satirical here i sent him
celibate yo you would not believe his
response i got instagram yo they were
like really i'm gonna challenge i'm
gonna break that tonight
yo dude girls are going crazy and i was
like yeah imagine if you were married
bro
how much target you are like you said
earlier it's crazy bro girls get mad but
i always say like having other women
makes you more attractive there's a
reason why women want to be in a vip
with a rapper when he has a bunch of
other chicks there why are you going a
music video set like you see girls have
different shapes colors and sizes like
men like variety it's been that way
since the beginning of time and even if
a guy has a main girl he's going to want
to have you know something different
every now and then now do most guy do
are all guys going to be able to enact
on it no probably not but if you give a
guy i always say you take the most loyal
guy give him two million dollars a
[ __ ] blue check on instagram a
lamborghini in a mansion for a couple
weeks he's probably gonna start smashing
some chicks
let me ask you guys one last question
it's 11 o'clock okay go ahead is it a
quick question it's a good question go
ahead if there's one song that every
woman in the history of women oh [ __ ]
likes what's the first song that comes
to mind
girls just wanna have fun exactly so i
wanna get your thoughts on why every
girl likes a song and
what they mean by just want to have fun
and obviously the more money you have to
sponsor this type of fun the more
opportunities you have so quick thoughts
on this song uh it embodies what girls
say for example i don't want to be bored
you know
you guys are funny i just think that my
wife's karaoke at my house the other for
new year so thanks a lot man so what is
it oh just to be quick uh basically it
embodies what girls want why don't have
a good time they won't stress they don't
wanna be annoyed they just wanna have a
good time they wanna be bored and as a
result a lot guys are boring so this
song means to them hey you know what
this is my anthem that you said earlier
i'm gonna have fun don't mess it up and
i want a guy who's gonna give me that
fun without any stress
yeah i mean if i'm gonna boil it down to
two words it's plausible deniability you
know uh girls always want to be able to
reserve the right to have that plausible
deniability like it just happened it was
natural it just manifested that's why
some girls are so into spirits or
whatever like you know women get the
privilege of like being able to say oh
what's your sign and all this other [ __ ]
and imagining stuff but guys we actually
got to go out there and make it happen
because i always say men live in a
fact-based rally women tend to live in a
disney fairy tale so girls just want to
have fun it creates plausible
deniability it's ambiguous enough where
you don't not really know what they mean
by fun but let's be honest it typically
means partying meeting other guys
hanging out doing [ __ ] and it may or may
not lead to having sex but you know i'm
not being judged and not being judged
there you go go ahead tyler all right
real quick super chat
from cc do you guys ever miss your old
life where you were more private and
more a target
oh
good one you want you want to hit it
first
you know what's funny bro i got way more
girls i was more happy when i wasn't
anybody because i just felt like i could
do what i want without being looked at
with a magnifying glass now it's kind of
like oh he's talking to her let me look
at her pass oh he's doing this it's like
i'm just having fun man like leave me
alone boys just want to have fun
thank god you're celibate now so you
don't have to worry about any of that
bro right
not anymore but uh
fellas go ahead uh myron yeah no awesome
thoughts yeah i got i got i definitely
got more girls before i mean for me it's
different because i used to i just be a
federal agent so like you would
you know you would have your privacy
that was very important right so like
now being in the limelight it's like a
180 change so i got more girls and
definitely was fun um i like what i'm
doing now i love it but it was a
completely different lifestyle from what
i was doing a couple years ago all right
so here's what we're doing so the
takeaway today
is the following okay
fresh as a pastor okay
myron's eventually going to be married
with kids
having a blast right now getting tens of
millions of eyeballs which is hard to do
okay creating a podcast and building it
up ain't easy folks i'm just telling you
you got to entertain you got to create
controversy you got to piss people off
you got to make people laugh but you
keep coming back so if you want to find
out more
about their podcast and you're not
subscribed to put the link below for
people to go find them find out about
them fellas i really enjoyed having you
guys on this conversation
it was great how many guys on thank you
felix it was great having you on as well
well coming back and having said that
are we doing podcast thursday or no yes
podcast thursday with leon cooperman
perfect oh leon here's a guy that's
worth a few billion dollars that they
said what did i do wrong to an interview
with wapo and i called them up i said
listen i know you worth 30 billion
dollars can we talk about
why they're giving you so much [ __ ] for
you being rich he said let's talk about
on the podcast on thursday don't miss it
take care everybody we'll see you there
you